it was prophesized
that on august 15th parents would revolt
when they saw what schools were doing to
their children prophesied by a man named
steve bannon who has returned as the
prophecy has been fulfilled steve how's
it going man thanks for having me tim
pretty good call
yeah you were right it wasn't that hard
i know i it was not you and i talked it
was not that hard you know when when
they had the crt issue and then the mask
issues you knew when kids were going to
come back to school the mothers of
america are going to go whoa whoa what
are you doing vaccines mask
social separation what's happening so
but it's actually bigger than i thought
it was going to be really really yeah
because i think this firestorms i think
is very big and i think the way they
tried to gun deck the um the fda report
yesterday and not have full disclosure
really what was going on well let's get
into that stuff we have a couple other
stories too obviously we'll talk about
afghanistan we've got something going on
there yeah i think so
we'll we'll google it maybe we'll get a
snippet from cnn and see what's
happening uh but we also have oregon
implementing outdoor mask mandates so
we're of course right we're headed back
in this direction we got new york uh you
know new york's vaccine mandate has no
medical exemptions that means on
september 3rd every company must fire
the disabled employees who can't get the
vaccine that's how draconian this is
getting obviously we also have australia
wow is it getting bad down there they're
arresting people they're putting signs
on doors so we got to talk about a lot
about that authoritarianism and
everything like that uh so i don't know
do you want to we'll do the traditional
introduction i think most people
probably familiar with who you are if
you want to introduce yourself real
quick
steve bannon welcome i'm a um you know
longtime viewer
first time caller um no
i'm a huge fan of the show huge fan of
you guys and your audience and so i'm
very honored to be back oh man thanks
for coming to more honors beautiful one
of the most beautiful parts of the
country good folks appalachia man
mountains and trees the weather is so
nice it's so it's one of the scott's
country
right on hey glad you're here steve
thanks good to see you again buddy okay
i get i got a bone to pick with you no
no no you've been in my head this role
no no no no no
no before the show
okay before the show it was amazing
what did you okay i don't wanna i don't
know let's hold it for later hold up for
later so uh i'll just say we're gonna
have the after show at timcast.com for
members stay tuned because this one's
going to be really really fun
there's a lot to talk about
yeah
there was great graphics
steve but it's going to be a fun comment
go to timcast.com be a member and you'll
see that coming up but uh ian oh hey
thanks for having me tim yeah great to
be here also a big fan of the show
yeah
i love tuning in yeah tuning in even
when i'm not on i like to watch so it's
great to be here yeah there's a deep
state and then there's ian yeah ian does
watch the show the schumann residence is
vibrating
and i think our thoughts are
for a while i was like your thoughts are
creating and changing reality now i'm
realizing this your thoughts are like
low frequency
wide range things that slowly affect
great distances but the camera's
increasing the frequency and shortening
the range so it's giving people this
like short range
version of your thoughts wait if you're
saying that we can say things they will
manifest
it's it's to be more likely that it's
going to manifest more with this
heightening this intensification test
gavin newsom gets recalled yes
this was this was this was dan rather
kenneth what is the frequency remember
i was just listening to that song that
rm song last night what's the frequency
kenneth
synchronicity there you go
i've actually been just doing a vulcan
mind mode on your okay
let's meditate
you weren't really listening that song
last night yeah what's the frequency
kenneth what's up
that's the famous fan that's the famous
dan rather than the night before last i
flipped it on someone left a comment and
they were like kenneth's frequency and
then you're weirding me out right now
we got to say this for the for that for
the for the for the member segment
there's a lot of talk about the member
segment obviously stuff that youtube
doesn't allow us talk about so but uh we
got lydia yeah ian was saying how our
thoughts manifest into reality and i
said larry elder will be governor of
california because i truly believe i
hope really hope that's the case
larry elder is governor of california
that's right and the people are like
yeah that doesn't make sense but like
think about that you talk about the i
just think about january we started
shifted from um impeachment to pandemic
mid january 2020 we called the pandemic
because we knew china
the four i would argue the four most
powerful politicians in the country that
time
donald trump mike pence
cuomo and gavin newsom because remember
biden was about to finish fourth or
fifth in iowa and fifth in new hampshire
he was a nothing burger right
think about it in one year president
trump
i can't say he won but president trump
is at bedminster right getting ready for
his uh for his second term power and
through pence is a 0.0 anywhere
non-event
cuomo's gone
and gavin newsom is about to be going
within 30 days this tells people this is
a fourth turning anything can happen
decades but
there are decades in which nothing
happens and then there are months with
decades happening that's why just right
strap in you have no idea think about it
those four politicians at the top of
their game
right and all four in different arenas
right now obviously president trump's
still the most powerful political force
in this country but the other three gone
and cuomo and newsome which are looked
at as the future of the democratic party
as far as power players both gone within
30 days a lot of optimism and hope you
know telling people these are these are
these are you're right you know anything
victories for you and your life for
politics anything can happen don't let
anybody tell you hey this is going to
happen you have no earthly idea this
thing is moving so dynamic every day
let's let's start talking about the uh
the mayonnaise and stuff like that and
the authoritarianism that's been
creeping up before we do go to
timcast.com become a member because we
got a bunch of awesome journalists doing
a lot of hard work and we're gonna have
a members only segment which comes up
around a lot
i would say normally 11 p.m but i have a
feeling this one will go long because
it's going to be a whole lot of fun
there's a lot of stuff youtube doesn't
allow people you know us to talk about
so we'll probably get to talk about a
lot of stuff crazy stuff you know ian
graffian whatever and uh it'll be it'll
be really interesting and that'll be at
timcast.com but don't forget to like
this video subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends if you
think it's worth sharing um even if you
don't like us and you want people to see
it that helps too i guess if you for
some reason want to help us but let's uh
let's jump to this first story out of
oregon
because it kind of so obviously the big
thing i want to talk to you steve about
is your prediction on schools but i
think this uh the authoritarianism we're
seeing is a good lead-in to what is
happening because well let me first read
the story
we have from the hill oregon
implementing mass mandates outdoors
regardless of vaccination status
so the issue the issue here obviously is
that we got new york mandates we've got
la's and announced them but we don't
know exactly when new orleans is
implementing them soon uh what do we got
we got there's four cities san francisco
san francisco is going in effect i think
soon i think new york is the one that
happened now this is medical apartheid
absolutely this is apartheid this is not
there's let's talk new york city for a
second de blasio is in msnbc today and
says we had on the show this morning
says oh we got to just we got to have
carrots and sticks and it's time to stop
the carrot we had enough carrots it's
all sticks okay and the big stick he
wants is on children he says five to
eleven he says the fda thing now we
gotta take we have to have mandates
mandates mandates to have that school
the fda think doesn't even deal the
children's studies aren't even coming
into 2019 to
2023 and 2024 right it has nothing to do
with children 5 to 11.
20 only 29 of african americans in new
york city are vaccinated i think only 40
percent of
of uh healthcare workers before they
start putting these mandates in why
people are logical and rational they
just want to see the receipts these are
not anti-vaxxers they're not the bobby
kennedy crowd and i'm not denigrating
that crowd but they got their own deal
this is vaccine hesitant and you're
seeing this about informed consent and
treating people like adults i agree i
think there's two big things that the
despots don't play uh don't factor in
we have uh
i we we have personal friends who are
pregnant you know and and so they go to
the doctor and their doctor says well i
wouldn't recommend any kind of you know
particular medication in this degree
that's my that's my recommendation say
at the doctor now the cdc says pregnant
can get it but what do you do when your
doctor says no so there's a lot of
they're saying oh why aren't enough
people getting their second dose why
maybe they're going to their doctors
getting informed consent making a choice
that's personal to them yeah
so yeah so when you when you mandate
these things with no medical exemptions
that's why i agree with you on medical
apartheid and for those that aren't
familiar apartheid is the afrikaans word
for segregation
but hardcore segregation i mean no no no
middle ground this is why african
americans in new york city right now
can't go to
according to the rules of de blasio
can't go in and have a nice dinner in a
restaurant right because you have to
have the passport and remember the
passport i think naomi was been quite
correct on this the passport leads to
many many other things well it's also
vexer id you don't just it's more than
the passport you need a
government-issued identification yes so
this is really interesting because um on
twitter i tweeted vaxxer id as racist
two two points one most of these
democrat types did not know that the
mandate requires photo identification as
well as your is your proof of
vaccination so they thought i was
talking about the passport i was i'm
literally talking about the id and
making a point that if you have just the
id issue where the left frequently says
minority communities are less inclined
or able to get ids well then if voter id
is racist under the same exact
principles acts or ideas racist as well
regardless of vaccination status they
didn't get that
when i finally started tweeting back at
people saying here's the law you need an
id they said oh well it's not targeting
them so it's fine
all of that ibram candy critical race
theory stuff goes out the window no one
cares anymore when it's their tribe
implementing the authoritarianism
i tell you i think this is it looks i
think the fda letter yesterday they
thought it was going to have a massive
impact it's not the story they thought
it was going to be and it's going to
lead to i think the implementation of
certain mandates they hope the
corporations come in here we're going to
have a real problem this is going to be
a lot if you think that the convergence
to the
the the
mothers on august 15th with going back
to school you wait till they start to
try to implement some of these mandates
i think you're going to have a lot of
problems a lot of problems with people
uh civil disobedience and people just
questioning this and i think the
lawsuits are going to really start to
start to fly so you're saying beyond
mass management you're saying schools
implementing vaccine mandates for
children this is where they're going
that's a remember let's go back in time
faunchie let the cat out of the bag when
he he said back a couple of months ago
we picked it up
a interview in the associated press they
started talking about herd immunity and
remember they've taken out what real
herd immunity is which you have the
disease you have the uh you get
antibiotic natural antibodies from
having the the virus okay that used to
be seventy percent remember we're all
going to go to herd immunity seven
percent they don't even mention herd
immunity today what you have to have
it's about she says oh no we got to get
everybody vaccinated and they shifted
the goal post even they're from 70 to 90
and i said look the math works there if
that's the case tonight you have to have
every school the school children have to
be vaccinated
savannah guthrie i think he asked him a
couple days later he kind of he kind of
coughed it up right they've now shifted
the goal post that it's got to be only
vaccines not hurt immunity right that's
the medical medical exemption the thing
if you have antibodies the way i think i
read the new york law you're not exempt
you still got to get vaccinated although
you have antibodies andrea mitchell
mitchell asked fauci the other day on tv
he she goes hey
couldn't we have a system and she says i
don't know the technical technicalities
or the expense but could we have thing
to test
your antibodies after this is about the
second jab and he went nuts no no no no
you can't do that absolutely can't do
that they do not want to go in and test
for antibodies about these vaccines
remember conspiracy theory on like the
tim pool show you'd have been bounced
off of youtube 90 days ago of we had
said oh really you're going to have to
have more jabs remember that's
conspiracy theory now dave rubin got
suspended on twitter that's my point
for that exactly and this was like a
month ago the difference in time from a
conspiracy theory now to fact is about
30 days 60 days right you would have
been banned dave rubin was and we yours
if we had talked about that you would
have been banned okay and now it's fact
now they're talking about multiple
jabs right jabs and so
this is a yearly booster or maybe even
short-term you look at israel look
here's the thing is that it's about
informed consent and that's why
people have logic and rationality and
it's like the african-american community
in new york why only 29 they haven't
been the argument has not been made to
them the evidence and facts have not
been out there that they agree with it
and this gets to be i think a lot of
this thing in in oregon
if you've had the vaccine the whole
question about mask is totally up in the
air at best you know i would argue
particularly open air right where is the
evidence where's the peer-reviewed
journalist that says you have to do that
right and and but you've got this
authoritarian you know the public health
system has now gone through this kind of
authoritarian mode where people are
doing it and that's where you're going
to have you're going to have a lot of
parents and i think you're going to see
a lot of parents just opt out of the
system i think you're going to see a big
surge in homeschooling they said hey
look i've had enough of this i've always
supported public schools you know i'm a
big supporter of this but i can't do
this anymore i'd rather take my kids and
figure out another way the mass things
is is particularly weird right so the
first thing i say is like i'm a very
i don't know what the right word is for
it i i don't care if people want to do
things with their own lives if you want
to wear a mask i'm that's absolutely
fantastic in fact if i if if you know
you're sick can you put a mask on i
think that's fantastic you're not
spitting on people right we see it all
over the world when people would have a
cold or flu they could put it on asia if
you've been going to asia for years
people in asia particularly in korea and
in china would wear a mask all the time
one is the air like in shanghai and
beijing is not great right but people
would ask all the time it's not it's not
a big deal if they were sick right we're
not even sick a lot of people just wear
it because the
action was so the air was so bad
it was it was nothing out of the
ordinary to see people totally messed up
a lot of them and that's your purely
your right so so there's this story out
of australia where they actually run
this their they have a warrant for this
guy and part of the complaint they show
on the news is that he was sneezing and
coughing an elevator without covering
his mouth and i'm like we all agree dick
move
but to issuing a warrant for someone's
arrest over this
i think what it shows with oregon and
the and the mandates of these things is
that
we are inching ever towards a paranoid
nanny state where people are so
terrified of reality that it's it's a
crime to sneeze in public without
covering your face let's go back to
reality this is where i think it really
gets dangerous because we try to be
evidence-based database science based on
the show every time we try to bring up
experts and walk through the data my
fear here is scientism now you have
irrationality coming into it and you
can't actually argue or you can't
present facts that you have and let's
let's talk about australia
everybody's been there no australians
know it's it's a country that it's an
outdoors country they love freedom
right uh it's not just because of the
you know the way they were founded with
the prison populations of of of the uk
um but
the the logic they have is like zero
coveted transmission or zero you know
these lockdowns are the most serious
i've seen you've seen the swat teams
going around you've seen the warrants
issued you see the national team and the
doxing people on national tv they're
building camps more than one
to try to because they're doing
something that's not rational you can't
get to zero
it's it's the law of diminishing returns
right what you have to do to get there
and it's not even a goal that you need
to have
because the disease is not that is not
that is not that deadly and the
transmissibility even this the other
thing the other thing about the fda
letter let me be blunt and this is dr
malone on the top vaccinologist that the
creator of the messenger rna
right he goes through he's he's not
anti-vaxxer he's dedicated his life to
vaccines he said the first thing is he
reads it and he
he says the letter is they only deal
with the data on the alpha and bravo
it's not the delta variant is not dealt
with at all in the analysis of remember
it's not the fizer it's the other one
well by the way he says it has not been
it's not on the market yet it's too [ __ ]
you can't go to anyone no no first off
the fda approval letter doesn't deal
with the delta variant they say in their
of the data
they did it off the alpha in in bravo
and other variants so there's no delta
variant the the other part of it is that
is that this was it the bio
tech or whatever the other name yeah
he says he doesn't know if that's in
full manufacturing yet it's not like you
can call the doctor and go get that
today that's going to be released but it
hasn't been released so far the delta
variant one or i'm confused no the
so they came out pfizer didn't actually
get a lot they're still under emergency
use authorization wait pfizer still is
yeah pfizer i think there are two
lessons widely reported that the fda has
already approved it no it's the if you
read if you read the details it's bio
energetic is the one that got the fda
approved for a full fda approval
pfizer slash bioentec is one vaccine
well no i think there's i think it's two
it's the pfizer company but that that
biotech is not the one that's fully been
has fully been out according this is
according to dr malone who walked
through the letter in detail today i
mean
and and his point is is that
he's not sure that they really cover his
point is that look you have a process in
these fda
approvals you always have they have an
independent advisory panel and you're
supposed to have public comments they
totally went beyond that they actually
say in the letter
uh because we didn't really have any
problems right we're not going to go
we're not going to have the outside
advisory board review this and we're not
going to have a public comment section
that's insane i don't i don't i don't
know if i agree because i don't know who
this guy is but i have dr malone is like
one of the he's the founder of the the
mrna the guy with the white beard you
say all the time
right i can't argue against him he's not
here but i did pull up from the fda.gov
fda approves first coveted 19 vaccine
they say today the u.s food and drug
administration approved the first
cova-19 vaccine the vaccine has been
known as the pfizer bioentech covet-19
vaccine and will now be marketed as this
is weird community yes for the
prevention of cova 19 disease and
individuals 16 years of age or older the
vaccine also continues by the way this
is also about de blasio it's 16 years
and older it has nothing to do with
people under 16. they say in the letter
itself it is eua for anyone under 16.
exactly right and you've got and by the
way they do have studies in there that
you're going to have and the studies i
think are deliverable the peer review
studies are in 2023 and 2024.
so my whole point is that
this is a moving target right now right
but you're going to have
and they're looking for the corporations
to do it and the corporations they have
these actually ironclad
uh mandates in there these ironclad
mandates that to keep your job to come
to work to be in an office to be all
that to go to a restaurant you're going
to have to have you're going to have to
have to be vaccinated and i think that's
going to cause a big disruption first of
all we know the anti-vaxxer crowd is not
going to do it right i believe that
there's enough of what i call the
vaccine hesitant right or the vaccine
hesitant adjacent
that need to be that need to really be
convinced the problem with vaccine
hesitancy is a phrase and i love that
you're you're kind of pointing out how
ridiculous because i'm i'm i love
vaccines functional vaccines are
phenomenal but a new unapproved vaccine
any human i believe in their right mind
should be hesitant about an unproved
vaccine that doesn't make me vaccine
hesitant just because i'm hesitating
about a new medicine that hasn't been
tested yet
doesn't make me hesitant towards
vaccines i like vaccines when they work
i understand what you're saying but i
think the main issue is
i brought this up many times i go to the
doctor i say hey doctor you know my back
hurts and he says here is fliblabal or
whatever and i'm like great and i have
no idea what it is you know for me i
google search it i do some research i
don't just blindly and there but your
body's not a temple
uh you mean like in terms of a doctor
giving me prescribed medication and me
being like i'm just saying it's a
general concept i mean i try to take
care of myself to the best of my
abilities but if a doctor or if the
doctor gives you something you're just
gonna go to the pharmacy and get it done
and take it typically i'll google it
i'll look up side effects i'll look up
things to consider and my point was i've
actually gone to the doctor and said hey
doc according online it says there's a
side effect for this and he was like we
can switch it out for something else and
i said cool and then i looked it up
again i said i prefer this this makes
more sense thank you doctor i think it's
it's really just about um
are you going to a doctor you don't
trust and i understand a lot of people
say there's a lot of bad doctors i'm
like okay then work to finding a good
one because you can't just
i don't know man go online and find a
blog to tell you what you should or
shouldn't be doing you got there's got
to be someone who knows your medical
history and this is the problem i have
with the celebrity push
and the mandates
there's a there's one in the story now
where it's like i think in new york a
judge ordered as bail terms you have to
get vaccine and i'm like this guy could
have a at any number of risk factors or
or underlying conditions or disabilities
and it's not for the judge to mandate
something that that he doesn't he's not
he's not a medical practitioner so they
that youtube comes at us and and and uh
other youtubers and says if you say the
wrong thing about the vaccine then oh
we're going to ban you but feel free to
give medical advice if it's the device
we like and i'm like no i don't want any
of that because i don't want to get sued
okay i don't want to be responsible for
someone else's health decisions but to
your point ian i agree if people are
like hey here's a new medication on the
market i'd like to look into this a
little bit maybe be a little hesitant
my ultimate thing is like get a couple
of opinions from doctors yeah and then
do your own research as well but see
this to your point that's why i think
people are
and i think the vaccine hesitant
are digging their heels in more and one
of the reasons is like we talked on your
show last time about we knew this date
was coming when people go back when the
go back to school and a lot of parents
have had the vaccine just don't think
there's enough
research done on children and yet you
had de blasio on msnbc this morning
saying hey we carrots and sticks we
gotta do five to eleven and yet you read
the letter and you see it's still
emergency children right referral
children so that's what you meant when
you said it was still under eua is for
the kids yes yes yes and we and we do
have that from the fda's website but but
but you see fouchy yesterday and i don't
think there's a slip of the tongue
because i think i definitely heard on
npr but i thought i also saw it on on
msnbc where he said hey now that we're
getting it as we get up to 90 or
whatever we can have our hands around
this our arms around this uh a plague
by the fall of 2022 and of course the
politicians blew up the democrats blew
up and he walked it back on anderson
cooper last night my point there's been
so much information put out there that
has just been inaccurate to the point
about the other jabs which which got
dave rubin taken down off of twitter
would have gotten us cancelled off of
youtube uh that turns out to be the
correct thing 60 days later there's so
much in a complicated topic
so much is is being important given to
the american people that turns out to be
just not accurate right and they're
naturally inclined to say hey prove it
to me let me pull up the story we have
from timcast.com
two years to slow the spread fauci hopes
to have coveted under control by spring
of 2022 in an interview with cnn's
anderson cooper
fauci came out and said he misspoke when
he said fall and he really meant spring
and you know what
if it was a mistake okay
that's fine sorry i i i get it fauci
yeah you made a mistake here's the
problem do you buy that
it doesn't matter if i do okay it
doesn't matter first of all i
trust and and distrust of cnn and fauci
here's the real issue fauci could be the
nicest guy in the world fauci could be
you know he comes over for dinner and he
brings a casserole with him and you're
like oh you didn't have to do that
without you thanks so much but he's been
wrong too much it's not about whether i
like him or think of him as a bad person
or prescribe male intent it's that
he has flip-flopped on so much and so
here's the big problem there's no anchor
i mean literally like an anchor in the
ground for people to understand their
reality yes so when the news comes out
on thursday and says by fall of 2022 and
then the news comes out on friday by
spring of 2022 and then you go and talk
to mom dad brother sister relative and
they're saying we all got to do this
otherwise we're going gonna be locked
down until fall of 2022 and you say no
cnn said it was spring of 2022 what are
you talking about and then you're both
showing each other articles from within
10 hours of each other contradicting
each other because fauci doesn't know
what he's talking about
i see this a lot on facebook someone
will post a story and it'll say some
fact or guidance and i'm like that
story's from a day ago
it's already been contradicted
but they don't want to hear it because
they're like look i read the news this
is a new story it's from 12 hours ago
saying this thing is true and then i'm
like yes but he came out again and said
this and they're like i don't know what
you're talking about so now you have
people clashing into each other arguing
about what is or isn't and getting
banned for it the funny thing about dave
rubin getting suspended on twitter for
saying that booster shots were coming
was that he was actually he when he when
he got finally released from twitter
jail he's like here are the articles i
was reading and they said are booster
shots on the way booster shots may be
coming soon and now where are we at the
fda says i want to make sure i pull this
up because youtube is a is a fickle
beast they say
the vaccine also continues to be
available under emergency use
authorization including for individuals
12 through 15 years of age and for the
administration of a third dose in
certain immunocompromised individuals
you know what they didn't say
a third dose for all individuals
so when they're talking about booster
shots for everybody
that's not in the fda's letter for even
emergency use authorization they only
are referencing certain immuno
compromised individuals now when the new
york times comes out and says fda is
recommending a booster shot after eight
months but the fda comes out and doesn't
say that yep what am i supposed to base
my my understanding off of yep i i want
to just clarify this these boosters
moderna pfizer go so on so forth and
booster shots all for the alpha variant
for the original covid variant alpha and
beta alpha beta which are no longer the
problem what we're looking at right now
is a mutated version assuming it's going
to mutate again and again and again and
again so these vaccines are not for the
delta variant which is the current
mutated strand right so uh a lot of the
stories have just said the vaccine you
know retains a certain amount of
efficacy for the delta variance that's a
weak way of saying it's not the right
vaccine it's it's it's
yes okay right i'm trying to use my
words carefully
because for the nuance they're saying it
works
it wasn't designed specifically
targeting this this this that's that's
so important and for them not to be hype
to be shining spotlight on that is is
like so decent this is okay so the the
uh right after i was here uh what four
or five six weeks ago the uh surgeon
general of the united states came out
with this big report and said and
attached to this report said the surgeon
general went to the white house number
one health public health issue we have
right now
right not even covet it's misinformation
remember that it's misinformation that
that's now a public health crisis
misinformation and they listed you know
bobby kennedy and dr mccola and other
people all because the internet
i think one of the reasons that fauci
has so imploded
in
in in people and not just integrity but
people
with authority people really listening
to him is that shows like this like
warren and others
get so much into the details of these
things people just don't want to watch
general political tv anymore i don't
think they're really thirsting
for answers and for experts and for data
information to make up their own mind
not to be told
but
like in the like in the movies show
don't tell right they want to see access
to information so when fancy goes on cnn
and msnbc is speaking this kind of this
general
big picture phraseology and then it
changes and the goal posts change i mean
first you get hurt immunity of 70 from
people have had it next thing you know
oh herd immunity is 90 you've got to be
vaccinated right
people get naturally because i think
we're in a time and you see this in the
apes people are crowdsourcing knowledge
all the time
right now they're going to say oh you
have to be trusted yeah there would be a
trusted source for that information just
to clarify the apes is a reference to
the stocks to the stock to the
the game stop the eight nations like
four million individuals and they're
teaching themselves how to trade stocks
or they're having people come in and
they crowdsource they're becoming
experts they're not experts they're
becoming proficient in understanding
finance and economics and the trading of
stocks as they teach themselves i think
you're seeing across the board in many
many different areas look at the people
just two examples and this is populism
look at what people know about vaccines
and pandemics today
that 18 months ago would never know look
at look at critical race theory i know
so many mothers
who were let's say this not exactly a
students who were partying in college
people i know my age maybe some
relatives maybe a sister of mine that
are experts in herbert marcuse
no but they they know critical race
theory like andrew breitbart knew it i
mean they've gone through and studied
they've gone to the source material we
had a woman on last night from north
carolina they can give you chapter and
verse they never heard a critical race
theory derek bell you know
six months ago right but for
crowdsourcing and gaining knowledge to
going up a learning curve you're seeing
this in in every different area around
and i think people they want if you're
going to be managed by experts the
experts i think have to come out and
really lay out things
in a very definitive way that's a good
point i mean we're seeing more and more
people start to do research they never
would have done in the past the way i uh
uh this is interesting we'll talk a
little bit about bill maher in a second
but i was thinking i was thinking about
bill maher's show because of the news
about him rejecting booster shots
and i'm like
you know the problem with bill morris he
doesn't actually read into the news
he just watches the tv and then bases
his opinions off of what he sees on tv
and you know what that probably worked
when bill maher was younger and that's
how he got to where he is today the news
used to be only a handful of channels
so when he's coming up into prominence
there's a handful of channels you can
watch where you could get distilled
information he does his political
commentary based on this the information
he was presenting was probably wrong or
misleading but we didn't have crowd
research now 2021 bill maher comes on
this on his show he gets the covington
kids wrong right he gets a lot of these
things wrong and he doesn't understand
but you can see that he's clearly on the
side of
liberty or or or more so on the side of
that i think he's kind of red built
you think he's red pill yeah let me tell
you but there's
real quick just yeah no go ahead you're
right
but he he's like one percent you know
he's missing so much context and
information first of all his show i
think is one of the best produced shows
i've had a chance to be on there a
couple times and twice up front
his show's one of the best producers the
staff does an amazing job of the details
remember he is a stand-up comedian
they and very quick-witted so i i find
this stuff actually be pretty piercing
as far as getting to the point
let me tell you story about the pandemic
so they called me up to to come out uh
to um
in fact in february january right when
the pandemic started to come out and
talk about the primaries on bill maher
on bill maher yeah in the front the
front of the show when you come out to
this thing right like the second time
i've done i've done the panel years ago
about sarah palin but i said i'm only
going to do it
if we talk about the pandemic i've
shifted my podcast from impeachment to
pandemic this is the end of the world
it's going to be it's going to it's
going to change the world as we know it
you have to understand it and they go
fine i fly out there and staff's
terrific they come to me and they say
look um here's the deal
bill loves you it's going to be a great
session upfront but he wants to talk
about the primaries i want to talk about
bernie you can't mention the pandemic
i go whoa and the producer say hey all
we do is follow it we're watching your
show because it was the early stages i
said no no i said this is going to
change the arc it's going to change the
it's going to change the
the election
right and uh and they said
no we can't do that what he'll do in the
introduction
he'll introduce you as the host of the
new podcast war room pandemic but then
he wants to talk about politics although
the staff and these guys and he just
made a decision
and it was quite frankly to your point
it was a miss his staff was very much
saying hey we want to do the pandemic he
made a decision hey this pandemic thing
sounds like the flu from china let's do
i want to talk about hillary and i want
to talk about bloomberg and we'll talk
about those things are current however
i think and i think this is why
particularly in the trump movement the
populist nationalism i think bill maher
is someone
every week on woke culture you're seeing
what i call old lions like that
who come from a more of a liberty
although they're progressive they come
from a libertarian base right a
libertarian perspective that are at the
vanguard of of countering and throwing
off awokeness
i appreciate them um i think it's good
there's a lot of people you know he had
ben shapiro on recently you see the
bench appear on malcolm nance thing yeah
yeah and and and wow when i watched that
you really understand how you're out mad
i mean ben superior versus malcolm nance
that's not a fair that's outmatched not
just that but like i don't even know his
senior chief petty officer nance is is a
good man i don't agree with this plot
but he's outmatched by ben shapiro yeah
even with nance not there i was really
impressed with ben shapiro he's fast
he's knowledgeable it and it was and and
he look
bill maher is outclassed by benjamin
yeah you know so i'm watching that i'm
like wow you know like this is why
people this is why ben is like one of
the biggest podcasters and one of the
biggest personalities in this
and uh but you know what you end up
seeing with this is that bill maher
he should have known a lot more than he
did
and so to to like you know what happens
in these debates with the p you have
malcolm nance you have ben shapiro and
again benjamin class both of them in my
opinion
bill maher
here's one of these like left
progressive people say something and
i'll say oh i understand that okay i'll
agree with that and it's like bill if
you actually read the story you'd know
that they were wrong
you know so i get accused of being right
wing simply because i actually fact
check things and a good example um
well i don't want to get too much into
the but
when you see
the uh the news come out i think we'll
call you right wing for more than that
but that's okay no i mean that's the
that's the main like that's that's it
because when you factor it they come
back and say you're a right winger when
you have a fact so if i say something
like versus an emotion also something
like afghanistan is
you know
the general idea i said is a lot of
people who want to pass the blame for
what's happening in afghanistan the the
democrats want to blame trump the trump
supporters will blame biden ultimately i
think
full responsibility to a great degree is
george w bush for starting the war in
the first place obama for escalating and
keeping us there but
i think it is factual the nation
building not the war yes nation building
i think it is factually inaccurate to
say that it is trump's fault for what's
happening in afghanistan because it's
ridiculous it's not his plan it's
ridiculous he negotiated a peace deal
it's not being followed through and
trump has no leadership over the current
situation so it is factually inaccurate
to say that trump yes but what happens
then is they say ah tim's defending
trump and i'm like
in the sense that he's not the president
right now he has no control over what's
going on but then they'll call me
conservative because a fact will happen
i'll give you an example i i know
everybody who's listening they're going
to be like here he goes the economy
again do you think the economy is good
or bad
right now i think they can i think the
economy for working-class people is
terrible inflation's out of control
you're getting crushed every day it's
awful independent voters and republicans
would agree with you but democrats
overwhelmingly think the economy is good
right now because they bought into it
hard they're not giving you the truth
you saw the polling today in on usa
today
30 forget the democrats so overweight to
bide right now because they're still
they're still hanging on because he's an
orange man bad it's orange man bad
32 percent only 32 percent of
independent support
by biden's presidency is over the regime
is over it's now time to cauterize this
and make sure it can't do any more
damage permanent damage
permanent damage to the american people
and to our republic and that's what's
happening right now with the financial
what they're doing the passing these
bills they just had to vote today the
six trillion dollars they want to add
this regime is over and here's why
look at look at this poll from usa today
suffolk which is a center-left or
left-wing polling group
it's not the war room and it's not
it's not the tim pull show right it is
32 percent of independent support
approval biden biden went from a plus 20
on the day of his inauguration a plus 20
approval to a net negative 14. there's
never been a drop this quickly in uh in
uh in the presidency ever by anybody
this is an implosion and there's no
bottom to this guy there's no floor this
guy could get to the high 20s he just
announced look he sent a cia director
over to afghanistan to be lectured by
the taliban and look i'm a big guy about
and the cia the head of ca the head of
cia is going to fly over to have a
meeting to be told you guys are leaving
and getting out of here and now tonight
he just announced we're starting to
withdraw because it takes a while to get
the apparatus out the apparatus is
starting to be moved out and right now i
think daily mail reported there's
hundreds of americans have been
evacuated just hundreds and there's 15
000 estimated
from what we know we don't know nobody's
giving us a firm and i understand you
might not have it down to the fifth
decimal place but can we know if it's 5
10 or 15 000 are they in kabul are they
throughout the country and what's going
on look
american citizens citizenship
have some value you shouldn't just be
left behind like trash right and this is
why this is the presidency that's
imploding right now and nobody can sit
there and look at these inflation
numbers working class people
the inflation's out it's not transitory
it's because the way we're financing
this
it's out of control the wealthy are
going to get wealthier your audience
particularly under 35 i told you before
you're going to be russian serfs now
you're going to be impoverished russian
serfs okay it's just this is just the
math so so the the point i made
previously was that i'll get called
right wing for agreeing with you on
facts
right so here's a really good example of
that uh you said that joe biden's
approval ranked what 41
41 we have uh uh that's suffolk uh
usa today suffolk just gave us afternoon
uh we have civics which does the long
tracking 91 000 responses and they said
42 disapproval
what do you think the disapproval of joe
biden is among democratic voters what
number disapproval among democratic
voters got to be in the teens or less 10
12 max six six yeah six percent of
democrats disapprove of of of joe biden
orange man bad now
uh uh among republicans
what do you think his approval rating is
oh
probably republicans got to be nine nine
percent six three three yeah the
disapproval of joe biden among
republicans is 94
so that's why the proxy is the
independence exactly and that's what i
wanted to get to among independent
voters where it really matters the
numbers are remarkably worse than what
you said approval for joe biden is 31
among independent voters so maybe some
of these are partisan but we know
republicans think we know what democrats
think independent voters 58 disapproval
now here's what happens as an
independent voter and i say something
like binding's doing a bad job well then
you must be right wing because
republicans don't like button if you
don't you're conservative
now independent voters are 31 percent
just by citing that fact your right wing
right just by saying that fact exactly
and you know uh if i come out and say
anything good about joe biden
meaningless they don't care there's
there's there's doesn't matter no sorry
so i don't know there's a lot there's a
lot to good to say about him i really
liked when he was giving that speech and
he said we shouldn't be sending a next
the next generation of uh you know sons
and daughters to go find but that's also
fun
we've agreed upon that we understand the
nation we can't be there president to
say it i'm not saying he deserves a ward
for it i'm just like i'm glad he said
that you know okay i think donald trump
listen back in 17 when i was in the
white house the national security state
the apparatus and look i'm a veteran my
daughter's a veteran my kid brother's a
a veteran his wife we come from a family
that serves
the military in the intelligence lied to
his face this is not a miscalculation
they lied to his face and they've been
lying to people for 20 years but the
system wants to believe it
the system wants to believe it right
president trump was was said okay i'll
we'll we'll do it for a while longer but
we got to have a plan to withdraw we
have to have a plan to get out of here
but this is not the way you do it and he
was right and people need to understand
bush starts the war obama expands it
it's only been it's only been two
presidents i'm not so sure on the war
look the war when we first went at the
paramilitary groups in october coming up
on the 20th anniversary that after 9 11
i think october 7th where there's going
to be a veterans rally in dc that thing
is going to be quite large and intense
um it was the nation building it's the
shifting of the thing to all sudden we
want to build a democracy like ourselves
in the middle of central asia right
right
two trillion dollars ladies and
gentlemen two what what what would this
country be like take it when when trump
was there they said oh it's gonna cost
15 billion i said eric prince and i said
i said 50. eric said 62 turned up be
62.5 billion
what would baltimore look like if you
took 62 just one year right 62 billion
just put into baltimore 62 billion
opportunity cost yes was enormous the
opportunity cost is beyond the 62
billion the money you could have made by
investing 2 trillion is a magnitude into
american manufacturing why can't we get
the democratic voter base to understand
that
why is it that they're over
overwhelmingly behind the machine which
is stripping away their their resources
their value and their labor for things
like nation part of it in afghanistan is
because the american empire the
industrial complex murdered canada or it
looks like they take people out that
speak up against them so people are like
living in shocked terrorism
let me give you a fact look
at msnbc look at msnbc's program wheel
at night look at look at look at rachel
maddow and look at chris hayes those are
the two most important shows look at the
big pharma ads okay the democrat
democratic party were the leaders
for decades in going after big pharma
until about 18 to 24 months ago now the
biggest proponents of big pharma and the
controls that come around big pharma the
democratic party and i think they've led
this is why i think there's so many
democrats and that's why i think in
seeing the rio grande valley populist
and economic nationalists are starting
to sit there and go hey i'm not into
what these globalists are this kind of
this this this empire that they want to
you know the party of davos right the
financial city of london wall street the
globalist corporations right they
they've sold these people that your
sovereignty doesn't mean anything in
your citizenship you're not going to own
anything but you're going to be fined
the world economic forum hey you're not
going to own anything but you're going
to be great you'll be happy you'll be
happy right
this is all
it's a con you know why
the guy's pushing that on you they own
and they own a lot and now they want to
own your houses and run them back to you
they want to own every asset because
assets are exploding why they own all
the commodities that's why inflation is
getting so high they want to own it all
they they want you to pay for it by
renting right or they want you to pay
for it by by leasing right but they're
going to own the assets so the people
selling this to you own the assets right
that's the con and that's why you're
going to be russian service you're not
going to own anything i think people are
awakening to that like communist china
communist china look it's it's kind of
it's it's a that's a transnational
criminal organization that's state
capitalism it's authoritarian right and
it's a politics a dick total
dictatorship with a state with a handful
of industries right that's why she goes
down there and says hey the tech guys i
don't wanna you know they're not gonna
become oligarchs like in the united
states where they can shut down donald
trump they can shut down donald trump
they can disband him and he's got no
voice that's not going to happen bang
bang bang jack ma you think you're a big
shot boom boom boom and he wipes out 500
billion dollars of the deplorables money
it's your opinion remember when she
makes this decision he doesn't care you
know why it's your private equity that
wall street's put into these companies
remember the 500 billion dollar that was
lost is the pension fund money of the
workers in the united states that's the
greek tragedy part of this so we're
basically all already living under the
boot of the ccp 100 so but by the way we
could shut them down here's the thing
the tools it's just like that movie with
costner and you know the untouchables
what they said about prohibition you got
sean connery and cosmonaut and they're
sitting there and sean connery turns and
goes everybody knows where the whiskey
is in prohibition
do you have the will to take the axe and
walk across the street and beat down the
door and go to the still and blow it up
that everybody knows what the problem is
the problem is we're financing the
chinese communist party why because the
system works like that it's higher
margins off the slave labor of the
chinese people the biggest victims of
this virus the biggest victims of the
transnational criminal organization the
chinese country party is lao baijing
which is a term means old hundred names
that's the kind of the john q public in
china the old the old hundred names
right those guys bear the brunt for
everything they're the deplorables of
china they're the biggest victims
they're the slave labor that's what's
nike is using at a buck a day right to
sell the t-shirts but the whole system
is built upon that because the
exportation of that deflation of about
about
products in the in the in the keeping
down of wages throughout the world keeps
wages down in the industrial democracies
that's what we have to break the chinese
countries and we can do it if we tell
wall street you're going to have to do
it if we if we sit and put capital
controls we can stop lending to them we
can shut them down in 100 days if we
enforce it and we don't and we won't as
long as we have we're run by the party
of davos there's a shield for
these uh
the establishment here in the united
states and it's the media
and so you know everything you said when
you know they call you far right and all
that stuff
if if you took quotes
those quotes and attributed them to a
socialist progressive youtuber people
would be like oh of course
new yorker magazine they did the big
profile of elizabeth warren when she was
running for president and in the fall
the new yorker did one of the things
that hang out with her fifth paragraph
she goes you know we listen to steve
bannon
we like his ideas those a lot of the
ideas look
i'm not a right-wing conservative i'm a
right-wing populist right right you
either have left-wing populism or
right-wing i'm an economic nationalist
and a populist right i believe and by
the way that's because i i believe that
we don't need total state control you
need a what people need is a better
piece of the action so what i mean to
say is
you agree on with uh on the problems
with the the left-wing populists yes it
is solutions yes the problem is these
leptin populists won't actually listen
to you because the media tells them not
to
but that's why shows like yours and they
are because i tell you who's listening
people in the rio grande valley the
hispanics the the vanguard of the trump
movement and you're seeing this and
let's talk about the recall of gavin
newsom the golden boy in california 51
of latinos in california when he's
recalled it's because one of the core
elements of the traditional democratic
party has said we want this guy out you
know why it's the mass mandates and it's
the education we don't want these school
unions they want the teachers we have to
have our kids in school we have to do it
one of the biggest things we have on the
show is this woman lydia friend women of
watts and her big fight is that in a
competitive you know she's a grandmother
but she cares for all these kids and
watch she says in a competitive world
economy kids can't take off a year or
two not have been being schooled at home
they need to be competitive with the
kids in china and the kids in europe
that's why latinos are leading this is
the ironic part of this it's latinos
leading the call of the recall of
gavin newsom in those nine democrats the
nine centurious democrats spread
throughout the country except three of
them are in the rio grande valley in
texas uh cuellar vela and uh and uh
cuellar vela and gonzalez i think it is
corvilles and gonzales three down there
that are um that are
are old school ones retiring the other
two are tough tough tough democrats but
they understand the rio grande valley is
flipping for trump why border security
and illegal aliens competing for those
jobs at the lower ends of the scale
they're driving wages down
people are rational the reason listen
this is why the apes are so important
they don't want you to understand
finance they don't want you to
understand economics they don't want you
to understand how the system works i
would tell people hey
you won't have any conspiracy theories
when you start to explain to give people
the information where the system works
like right now
we've just had
bloomberg had this morning and i think
when you get to that bloomberg had this
morning that story
since the since the since the uh the ccp
virus four trillion dollars has been
added to the balance sheet of the
federal reserve to pay for the drop in
agrimen all those interim things four
trillion dollars
838 million dollars
an hour wow okay
now we're sitting here in washington dc
they're talking about six trillion
dollars of additional spending do you
understand that this is going to not
your children and your grandchildren you
if you're under 35 years old welcome to
serfdom okay because you're always going
to be just kind of this this uh what
lumping proletariat right you're never
going to own anything you're not going
to have any one or two that under that
write some algorithm are the elon musk
of the world yes you'll break out but
for the general population it won't be
the days of america where you could
support a family on one wage earner and
a couple of kids they're trying to
destroy the american dream
for themselves they've taken it off from
themselves remember they sit there and
they put that the party of davos with
that thing world you know build back
better oh you're not going to own
anything but you're going to be happy
you don't need to they own a lot because
you're going to pay by the way
you're still going to pay the rent right
are you still going to pay them they're
going to own the asset one of the
reasons they own the assets that's
because there's an explosion when you
have this uh when you have this printing
of money there's an explosion in real
assets that real estate stocks this is
what's going up they're the owners that
you're seeing the greatest
concentrations shift in concentration of
wealth in mankind's history right before
our eyes that's why it has to be stopped
now you do have power the debt ceiling
they can't they can't really get any of
the spending done until they increase
the debt ceiling and that's where the
people you're gonna have you think you
had a fire i called a firestorm
about this uh about the going back to
school on september 20th when they come
back from this recess and they have to
get down to brass tax the raising of the
debt ceiling is going to be the next
firestorm they're going to sit there and
go the deplorables and bannon and all
these crazies are going to ruin the
credit rating in the united states
they're going to implode the stock
market they're going to blow up the bond
market and do all this evil stuff right
all i'm saying is that the full faith
and credit you have three ways to pay
for things you sell bonds to the
japanese or chinese you raise taxes and
grow your way with increased taxes or
you print money
the only reason we can print money
remember the only reason we print money
is we're the prime reserve currency the
greatest export we have is the us dollar
every transaction in the world today now
the chinese are trying to get off it
cryptocurrency could get you off it but
every transaction in the world has to be
generally converted into a dollar that's
why it's the greatest asset is the
greatest export we have as long as we
have that we can keep printing money but
all that printing of money when it says
the full faith and credit of the united
states that's you that's your audience
it's on your shoulders that means you're
gonna pay it back your hard work your
efforts the world's depending upon you
the decency the decency of the american
people to make good on an iou
and that day that is now 30 trillion
dollars you project this thing out it's
it gets so far over the top in no
economy
they always say this time it's different
it's never different
once you cross once you cross debt to
gdp
boom and that's what we're hurtling down
this now they're here talking about six
trillion dollars and here's the question
look around your city look around your
state look at your own personal life
don't take my word for it we're at 30
trillion dollars face amount roughly 30
trillion dollars a face amount of debt
by the way the contingent liabilities
depending on your discount rate anywhere
from 110 to 250 trillion dollars
contingent liabilities but just on the
30 million a 30 trillion look around at
your state where'd the money go
where did the money go where did the
money go do you see great airports you
see magnificent highways you see great
light rail where did the 30 trillion go
where the 2 trillion go in afghanistan
but it's brown university the net
present value of what we spend in
afghanistan is 2 trillion dollars this
is what i asked when i was in the nsc
show me the hospitals show me the roads
show me the schools for girls this is
gotta be shangri-la it's 30 it's the
size of texas is 35 40 million people 2
trained this has got to be shangri-la
where did the money go right a lot of it
was left on the runway there in uh was a
kabul for the taliban to take in the
form of jets and fighter jets that's a
little bit millions of dollars each i
mean hundreds of millions of hundreds of
them kind of answering questions you
probably know the answers
the arms industry they make a bomb they
blow it up it's gone but they spent a
lot of money 20 million dollars making
the stupid thing or whatever they
decommissioned the jet the next year but
hundreds of millions of look these are
fighters and let's be honest we created
helped create the taliban to fight the
russians back in the back in the uh back
in the 70s and 80s or charlie wilson's
war but listen
the afghan people have defeated
essentially alexander the great the
british empire at the top of their game
the soviet empire the top of the game
and let's let's we've taken
the afghan national army
for hundreds of billions not 80 billion
hundreds of billions of dollars of your
money
we took the world's greatest fighters
toughest fighters to beat everybody top
of the game
and turn them into the world's worst
army that quit that quit
because you've been lied to you've been
lied to for 20 years and we accepted
these lies but uh uh
to clarify though they did quit
but it was uh biden my understanding is
he pulled air support and logistics
pulled logistics out of the system they
they pulled the maintenance they they
fled bagram air force base in the middle
of the night and then the afghan
security forces are like where's our
support we have this training this
doctrine and all of a sudden it's
crippled when the when the taliban
starts coming in and the commandos did
fight there's that video where the
commandos run out of ammo and then
surrender and the afghan i'm sorry the
taliban just come in and kill them all
eventually after weeks of this that's
when you see everyone just disband it
fell apart this whole aspect of what
happened in may june july and what biden
was told what what intelligence was told
this will be
in if not an impeachment trial
hearings that lead up to this because
this is that grave what was he told what
were the decisions made what was the
logic and who signed off of taking
giving up bagram first taking the troops
out first and leaving american citizens
there and the thing how do you do it in
reverse order who made those decisions
what intel what were the briefings
what'd they look like right here what
milly said
he was ordered to to guard the embassy
so they didn't set up a path to bagram
an air force base where they could have
been running evacuations instead they
tried doing it out of kabul's
international but this is where general
austin and general miller you got to
step there and go no we can't do this
because you're going to jeopardize you
know you we know your commander in chief
but we cannot do this and make the
national super national security advisor
in the run-up to this is he working 24
hours a day jake solomon no he's down in
brazil
lecturing bolsonaro on machine voting
for the for the for the big contest
they're going to have in in 2022 between
lula the the communist criminal and
bolsonaro a populist nationalist he's
down there lecturing him about his
election lecturing about election when
he should be in the situation room 24
hours a day we're sorting this thing out
all of that will come out now we're in
the middle of a crisis where they've
basically had the taliban tell them no
31st is a hard date you're out and
they're going to move the apparatus and
we don't know how many american citizens
look
i spent months and some people spent
years in the north arabian sea and
persian gulf back in i think 79 80 for
the
for the persian for the iranian hostage
christ there were 52 people we have
thousands and we don't know tim how can
we be sitting here in on august 24th and
we don't know today within a couple of
thousand how many actual american
citizens are and i'd say they're
hostages right now or because you're at
the tender mercies of the taliban to
allow them to go to the airport to get
out of there what was it movie with uh
ben affleck where they were uh trapped
in iran it was based off the true story
dude i'm talking about it was like in
the 70s i think it was this is there's
something about ross perot sending his
guys in to get the uh well in iran what
happened is that they took the embassy
in tehran right and sneak the people out
well no we had no the ross perot had a
company and he had employees there he he
went and did helicopter things he took
his people out we after a year or nine
months of humiliation
tried to send an attack force to get him
from the persian gulf in north arabian
sea it got to a rendezvous point and
kind of crashed and couldn't go couldn't
go into tehran we abandoned it
the day of ronald reagan you talk about
peace through strength and being
somebody being afraid of the new sheriff
the day of ronald reagan's inauguration
the mullahs sent the sent the hostages
back all of them right now one they want
to humiliate carter but
more importantly they knew there was a
guy in town that was not going to put up
with this nonsense okay that's where
we're seeing look you can hate
you can spit on the floor when you hear
donald trump's name
just be brutally frank
okay that's the world was not like that
last year okay it just wasn't okay now
we have a feckless hapless old man
that's clearly not in charge making
disastrous decisions the other question
i got
why do you have a president i say that
addresses the american people in the
middle of the afternoon okay why does he
be before the sun down or why is he
doing things at three o'clock in the
afternoon 3 45 4 o'clock on the west
coast it's lunch time you're addressing
the nation can you can you can you
they'll give you tv time this is a big
enough crisis i think they'll give you
tv time or even if just cable picks it
up let's have a talk at eight o'clock at
night when people are back from work
when people are back from work i mean
these are these are national things look
there's no floor
and talk about no coincidences rachel
maddow cuts her new deal rachael she's
because she's the brains of the
operation she's you talk about the media
she's she's the thinker and her team is
all of a sudden she wants to spend more
time with the family she's cutting a new
a weekly show from a nightly show and oh
she's going to start doing west wings
and entertainment and you know ari
emanuel you know and she's going to do
all kind of things no she just like jon
stewart she does not want to be left
holding the bag here she wants out okay
she wants out and i want to spend more
time with the family give me a break
she's the hardest worker and tougher and
hey on the rise of this she was all over
it she's seen it and they went out of
here because they understand
this is a debacle this is a debacle the
entire
every one of our allies is repulsed and
the chinese communist party a
transnational criminal organization with
their partners in pakistan that have
been run and been condemned us for years
with now the taliban in the in the in
the super state with al qaeda haqqani
and in isis plus turkey plus russia is
now going to consolidate the eurasian
land mass and they're going to be
looking at silicon valley west which is
taiwan forget what you think you have a
moral obligation to defend a democracy
think about the practicality you're not
going to have a refrigerator you're not
going to have an f-100 you're not going
to have an economy because that bill
they're trying to jam through is 20
billion to try to get the high-tech chip
design back to arizona it ain't going to
happen
taiwan is silicon valley west it must be
defended for the practicality of the
american economy and they're sitting
there right now looking at island 100
miles off in this hapless crowd here
that are going to leave american
citizens behind
let's so so the movie i was thinking of
was argo yes with uh ben affleck and
it's about the story the cia faked a
movie production to get uh people out of
the embassy in 1979 they pretended to be
like directors and things like that it's
a i thought it was a great movie um
how many people were were involved i was
a small handful 52 52 55 people at the
embassy by the way half of them were you
know intelligence
officers but they made them they made a
movie right about this about how scared
the americans were that we could lose 52
people think of 15 000. 15 000.
most american citizens in there are a
lot of progressives uh women from ngos
which are they're doing positive work
for women and things they they think are
health things that things are great this
is what right now we are potentially we
don't know the details potentially
leaving behind this could turn out to be
if not it already is the
most devastating hostage situation that
the u.s has ever faced
because uh they've already been warning
that many of these people may become
pows
what do you need to understand about the
15 000 people the taliban has said oh
don't worry we're gonna allow the
americans to get out but do they really
have
a rigid enough control of the the the
men you know in the taliban to prevent
them from saying
that guy's a contractor
we don't care about what they say and
then you get videos of beheadings
let's say 90 percent of the taliban
can be centrally controlled
that's 10
that are just
gonna go rogue they're going to
freelance you don't know but the united
states should never be in a position
that we're beholden to the tender
mercies of a medieval theocracy
right
and michael hayden let's be blunt
the national security state here
hayden tweets out the other day they had
a trump they had one of the things of
the of the trump threat with the trump
flags they had the taliban going by he
said uh the taliban and our taliban
right this a guy that was the only bear
i believe was cia nsa right then he
tweeted out the other day some guy
tweeted we ought to send all the
unvaccinated
to into on the planes don't let them go
back empty don't let them deadhead send
it back with unv when unvaccinated trump
followers and he retweets us thinking
this is cute in a time of a national
crisis and this is a crisis i got a
question for you you know
obviously
we're seeing this this mass chaos this
catastrophe but just uh with afghanistan
this potential hostage situation what
you were referencing with hayden we
we've been talking about quite a bit
something changed in people people i've
known for a long time who used to be
normal regular nice people have become
vile angry and bloodthirsty
why
have you have you noticed this so much
big time like all of a sudden they're
posting things like i hope you effing
guy man i'm like what happened to this
guy
like yo
calm down it's a fourth turning
it is turning people into some kind of
wear monster where this fourth turning
happens and all of a sudden they're just
like all of a sudden they're just
bloodlust you the weight how nasty is
going to get look remember one of the
big arguments they made against trump
and the in the trump team and in the
deplorables and american first and all
that is that you're a bunch of rubes you
breathe through your mouth you don't
know how the world works you want it
fortress america you're nativist
xenophobes racist we're the experts
we're dialed into the party of davis
we're delved into nato this is
competence
this is why at the core
what i said at the cpac in 17 we need to
deconstruct the administrative state
i'm not a guy that wants to burn down
institutions but you know what every
institution we've got is rotten to the
core and needs to have a cleansing okay
the fbi the cia let's take it again here
are some people fine and institutionally
go through we have to have like a church
commission on this how do we get in this
situation again after the failures on 9
11 after the failures and weapons of
mass destruction on the failures of not
seeing the rise of china right these are
not small things each one of these is
what would destroy a great power okay
they're the experts they're telling us
what to do remember 911 miss
weapons of mass destruction missed and
lied about it okay rise of china oh
nobody saw that what happened oh yeah
they're everywhere ccp is everywhere and
now in afghanistan that's where we got
to get to the bottom of what biden was
told and when he was told and we need to
see the briefing they can redact it and
this is why even you saw shift yesterday
shifts are you trying to get ahead of it
to save himself he does a house
intelligence then he walks down the
steps and goes he tells him right there
hey i just saw the potential briefing i
don't think we're going to get everybody
out that's a bombshell
what does that happen in american
history we're not going to get everybody
out
we're not going to get everybody out
we're just telling you now a week
beforehand we're going to leave them to
the taliban people need to start bracing
themselves for the possibility that
you're going to see some really awful
videos yep there's going to be a and the
news
the the the these
uh
establishment media outlets may want to
try and veer away from it knowing what's
coming in 2022 but you're not going to
be able to escape it on the internet i
think they're actually doing a
cnn in msnbc is i think doing it now
you've got the opinion guys they're
trying to steer it it's trump's fault
everything like that
but i think to date they're doing a
pretty good job of showing the chaos and
saying hey it's disorganized plus you
have that you have the state department
saying one thing in the pentagon giving
a briefing
and you have general austin and admiral
kirby and immigrant and they're like
looking around they get asked a question
oh the state department just said that
we didn't know that wow
they say trump's groups
is is incompetent this isn't this is not
incompetence this is gross this is not
negligence this is gross recklessness
you know what i was saying the other day
the afghanistan thing really revealed
the emperor has no clothes in a way that
um
you know it's kind of surprising to me
because of course i never saw biden as
competent we have we had a new poll
showing that most americans now view him
as incomp and it was a cbs poll not not
a competent president 52 percent yeah
pretty shocking right right and you had
uh rasmussen saying most americans view
kamala harris is not qualified to be
president but i always kind of felt
nancy pelosi is third in the third on
deck right and come on i'm just saying
you should not be able to do it third in
succession but here's here's what i was
you know i always kind of felt like even
if biden wasn't capable someone there is
the adult in the room who's like we'll
take you know okay bite in muttered and
fell asleep but we know what we got to
do and then i see with afghanistan i'm
like
no they've all just said don't look at
me it's biden's fault when when they
when they abandon bagram in the middle
of the night and then hayden says well i
was told to guard the embassy the
biden's whacked out of his mind you took
that advice when you knew milly doesn't
care he's a politician so all of these
people are like what my fault i was
following orders remember that bagram
one most important basis in in the world
not turned over to our supposed ally not
turned over to afghan air force not
turned over to the afghan security
forces not turn to the afghan army we
went out like a one-night stand in the
middle of the night and let the devil
catch a high most even
just the looters they gave over the
looters taliban then kept up
this shows you
that the globalist project
is collapsing around them okay it's
collapsing around them they fought for
this for 20 years they wanted the the
they had all the western educated guys
lying to them and believing the lies
here's the question the american people
should demand
where
simple question where did the two
trillion dollars go i know what the
source of proceeds were the american
taxpayer okay
or future american taxpayers i want to
know where the money went toilet
i mean look they they hired contractors
they built bases they built bombs they
built weapons they spent it on a project
that ultimately was fruitless the the
globalists skimmed off the top you have
more heroin trafficking today right than
ever before this is one remember the
washington post
uh and i kept saying this like two years
ago they did a thing called the afghan
papers which is more powerful than the
pentagon papers people talk about the
pentagon papers you read the afghan
papers that the washington post editors
put together with real reporting from
inside the pentagon it's shocking
because as many lies as you were told
about vietnam it pales in comparison to
the lies you were told about afghanistan
what was some of what were some big ones
well like we're making progress
we we basically destroyed the taliban we
control the country there's a
functioning democracy
year after year after like when i was
there
one of the things i was supposed to do
was work to get us out and what they
said is that oh no you know it's a
functioning democracy we control this
kabul we control the errors i said look
let's do two things let's just give me
this source give me the use of proceeds
where the money go
fight fight fight don't want to give it
finally have to demand it no and you can
round up to the closest 100 billion
right you look at the use of proceeds i
think at the time the afghan national
forces and securities like 500 billion
dollars of the two of the net present
value of the 2 trillion right also i
said i want to go back i gave a couple
of inflection points i want to see the
presentations that were given to the
commander chief at the time i just want
to see was at the time when bush made
these decisions when obama made the
decision because you've had both
conservative hawks neocons like uh
chaining these guys in this room and
you've had progressive neo uh neocons
and hawks in this room under obama
all good people all trying their best
all went to the ivy league schools all
from the military cabins all of it for
20 years let me see them let's the
presentation you know all the
presentations are this they don't want
to give it you know why all the
presentations all the same in 18 months
oh man you want to live in that it's
like it's like being an investment
banking the third year is nirvana right
every number is hitting in the third
year you're golden right that third year
the chart is like that every year it's
18 months we're 18 months away from
turning this thing around 18 it's always
18 months it's a lie this is not a
miscalculation they're lying to your
face they're lying to your face about
what nato supported the line but what
nader did on the combat tours they're
lying about what went on remember if you
ask anybody today if you google right
now how many deaths in afghanistan 2200
well no hold it you're not counting i
think 4 000 contractors and the
contractors are not guys rolling in
cooking hot dogs they're basically pipe
hitters that are that have punched out
of the military and it's cheaper to pay
them you know a real salary right but
not to pay their medical or not to pay
their retirement they're off the books i
think we lost four thousand uh uh uh
contractors so there's six or seven
thousand dead we don't know how many
for your audience right now i'm getting
calls i know a couple of people
individually personally close to me that
have had friends that have ptsd that
have tried to commit suicide or try to
hurt this house because they're sitting
there going 20 years of my life 10 tours
all my friends friends wounded hurt
lives destroyed and for what
what is it for what did we do were we
lied to by our face did anybody
anticipate if we in if the apparatus is
so smart if the experts if you're so
dumb out there and you're just somebody
that should be fed uh information that
that's packaged and they're so smart how
did we get to the end of a 20-year
project and yes joe biden you're right
we got to leave no doubt about it how do
we get to the end of the 20-year project
and there's nothing not only nothing to
show for it it's a terrorist super state
that's going to be created if the
experts are so this is why populism give
me the first hundred people that dial
into the tim cass are the first hundred
people that showed up to alabama to that
field the other night let me have the
country run by that than these experts
and we're going to have a country that's
decent hard-working
understands human nature and and doesn't
get into these crazy situations this is
all the experts conservative neocons
liberal neocons right all the experts
all the think tanks go back and look at
their lies this is not miscalculations
this is lies they lied they lied they
lied and who paid for it
in section 60 over there in arlington
national cemetery it's the kids of the
working class that's who's over there
okay who's wondered with the ptsd who
are having suicidal thoughts by and
large kids of the working class who's
going back over in harm's way the 500
they had to put in who are the the
afghanis throwing the babies up to the
afghans afghanis are voting right now
what they think about judeo-christian
values and about the deplorables they're
tossing their kids up hey i'm finished
i'm done the taliban's going to get me
but save my kid do you think that uh
or i kind of feel like one of the
reasons they they lied to trump tried to
keep our troops in afghanistan was to
prevent people finding out what was
really they're just trying to kick the
can down the road yeah they want by the
way they remember they showed him but
mcmaster thing i showed him like mini
skirts in the 70s that the oh yeah you
know before this all happened this was
like a modern western nation no it
wasn't this is not even a country it's
50 tribes yeah and the three big ones
with the uzbeks the tajiks and the
pashtuns at each other's throats right
this is not something that could beat
alexander the great that's where he died
okay the british remember the 16 000 man
army had 16 miles away they let one guy
come through to tell the tale that left
from from from kabul to go out through
the through the
kyber pass right the russians it
destroyed the russian empire collapsed
this is how empires collapse you know
what it collapses because working people
sit there and go i'm not believing this
anymore i don't buy it i'm not buying
into this you know why because they
treat me like you think they here's what
they think about american citizens they
think you're trash
it's not steve bannon saying that it's
they're leaving you back in college
exactly they're leaving you in kabul are
you a priority to get out no they're
leaving you who's who's doing it who is
responsible for making the call that's
making the american government print all
this money uh drop their troops and send
their troops overseas i mean dick cheney
halliburton wall street wall street the
global corporations wall street the
donor class and the uniparty and you
have a unit party look you had 19
republicans
sign up for this for this infrastructure
bill which is under a third
infrastructure here's the thing with
infrastructure they mock trump on amazon
say oh it's infrastructure week ha ha ha
trump's thesis was different it had to
pay for itself
this thing has by the congressional
budget office the first bill the 1.2
trillion 286 billion unpaid for new york
times saying 400 billion and i would say
the rest of it they say pay for it is
all voodoo it's not paid for okay it's
not paid for let's talk about the
collapse
so you said uh you just mentioned soviet
union collapses just after afghanistan
yes
we are uh an empire of sorts right
so we've become an empire yes so is
afghanistan going to be our demise
do you think
i think that unless working class people
step up and look at what's happened in
the rio grande valley if working class
people step up and say no more not my
kids not my money we're going to take
we're going to take charge of this we're
going to get back to some basic
fundamentals and we're not going to
retreat into fortress america i'm not a
retreat forts america we've got to have
we we will be throughout the world right
but not like we are today in everybody's
business spread out all over hell's half
acre sticking our nose in everywhere we
will be and we have to confront the the
existential threat which is the chinese
communist party okay we have to do that
and by the way i've said and their
philosophy is unconventional warfare
right the the the the you have economic
and cyber you have you have information
in cyber and economic right
then you have kinetic we are hurtling
towards kinetic war in the south china
sea and taiwan even as we speak so i
want to bring up this uh tweet from elon
musk that we saw earlier
daily mail says elon musk posts cryptic
tweet about the quote son of the old
world setting in a dying blaze of
splendor
he tweeted the guns of august it's a
book um about the early stages of world
war one he followed up with a tweet with
a lord of the rings reference he's not
responded to comments about what he
meant
but um
he said nine rings for mortal men
following after after he said that well
the guns of august are very prophetic i
mean the following quote was one of the
guys trying to negotiate a piece to make
sure we didn't go to war was
said the lights of europe are going to
go out never to be relent in my lifetime
remember 1914 what happened with the
assassination in serbia in late july
excuse me late june
basically five weeks later
they they had these treaties
in the in the and the mobilization it
kind of took on a life of zone and
actually were drawn to a war
from august of 1914 that war did not end
until the fall of the berlin wall that's
why the 20th century is the most bloody
century of mankind's history when they
look back at we lived it you in this
audience
were some of you
were born in what would be called a
modern dark age
250 million people died were slaughtered
in the 20th century through war
starvation of what happened in august of
that's why the guns of august anybody
who wants to read barbara tuchman's book
will see when the experts when the
experts know everything remember europe
was a hundred years of peace since
napoleon was finished it was the great
industrial remember the steam engine we
we exploded on industrial production
everything the wealthiest the world's
ever been the most trade the world's
ever been the most united the world's
ever been a globalized system the world
it created the victorian values cratered
before our eyes into a sea of barbarity
okay
that ended with you know the camera
rouge and in in mao se tang and all that
and eventually afghanistan which brought
down the soviet empire and eventually to
the berlin wall that from 1914 to 1989
the bloodiest the short 20th centuries
is bloodiest century in mankind's
history and elon musk who's a smart guy
i think is sitting there is this is this
new globalization order is it going to
be is is is afghanistan
is that the guns of august in other
words is that the is that the
assassination in serbia that leads the
dominoes to and quite frankly
people ought to be very concerned and
right now you should be cutting off the
football and cutting off the baseball
you should be watching the news you
should be thinking
what is going on here what is going to
change in my life what's going to change
in my children's lives right have you
been tracking the food shortages
pretty uh pretty scary yeah
uh
how does it affect you a lot of people
might not notice it depending on what i
think a lot of people might be noticing
you go to taco bell for instance and
they got a sign up saying we don't have
these food items go to starbucks and say
we don't have these food items my uh uh
i'm trying to order uh food for for for
my pets and they're like this is out
this can't be bought went to the pet
store and it was like 50 bucks for cat
food yeah it's getting harder and harder
to to
secure and supply these things you know
combined with those things we've had the
greatest increase in in prices i think
in 50 years right it's not trans story
the federal reserve says oh it's all
transitory not don't worry about it but
ain't transitory particularly working
class you're getting eaten alive we knew
it wasn't those of us who have been
tracking this i'm sure you knew that
these prices would stay up the idea that
oh don't worry it's just playing your
bettors you know you say that but you're
betters the governors of the federal
reserve all the economists they sat
there two months a month ago and said no
you're wrong tim
this is transitory right it's just a
slight blip everything's fine
you're not an expert go back in your
cave go back and shut up and sit down
pay your taxes put your pension money in
that'll that'll grease the system we'll
control all the assets and you're going
to pay us rents because you're going to
pay the carrying cost this is one of the
reasons i got out of the cities you know
i lived in uh i lived in new york and
then there was protests and things were
getting bad and then some cops got
assassinated in front of my apartment
over on myrtle and noah's trend right
around there uh thompkins i think it was
and so i said you know maybe it was
political it was it was a black
nationalist killing cops he said you
take two of ours we take two of yours
and so i said maybe i shouldn't live in
this city because you know i've already
seen the protests and i see the
escalation happening before my eyes i
move over to the jersey side i'm like
you know i'll still work in the city but
i'll stay out of the the density of
things and then there were bombs planted
in manhattan and jersey city and i said
okay maybe i should move a little bit
further away
then we i you know i end up going to
south jersey i see the riots the right
the black lives matter rights the george
floyd writes and i said yeah well we're
on the other side of the river from
philly so we're fine then i heard the
helicopters and they started coming into
the suburbs the protests the riots and i
was like they crossed the bridge
you know what i'm not gonna sit around
to wait and find out where the
escalation leads to and so we ultimately
end up going out to the west virginia
you know we're in like the harpers ferry
area which is not the middle of nowhere
mind you it's like an hour from the
airport but i'm still thinking like we
need space
we need to have our own water source
because
the world may not be ending i don't know
but the point is i want to just make
sure that when whatever ends up
happening be it a disaster or crisis or
something in the united states i have
taken responsibility for myself because
the worst case scenario is we got a
great place we got trees we got deer
walking around we it's beautiful it's
fresh air we have our own well
and you know what maybe it's it's good
to prepare for some kind of chaos that
may ensue maybe it will never happen
well the worst case scenario is fresh
air and clean water how about that
i don't know what you're thinking st are
you you know about cities well i think
look
people have to make individual decisions
individual choices i think one of the
things that people have to do is to get
sources of information and check them
and verify them but much of what you're
being told is just not accurate 30 days
later changes 60 days later changes you
were told this inflation's in transitory
it's just not because asset classes
assets and by the way people are putting
money into commodities food prices are
going up this is
the most massive unfair tax for
working-class people and you're going to
see a revolt that's why biden's handling
the economy is down now into the 40s and
sometimes in the 30s depending on who
the demographic by the way for the other
day an economist poll not the war room
and not tim poole the economist yougov
poll
had the crosstabs which by the way most
of these polls today do not put out the
crosstabs because they don't want to see
how bad when you get into the details
the economist did 250 pages steve cortez
and uh and raheem kassam went through it
and they had in the in
the span looking at hispanics
biden's handling the economy excellent
zero point
zero first time i've ever seen a double
aught in an opponent usually you get
something
0.0 excellent okay
people are wising up to it because they
see the reality of their lives and all
you have to do to think about these
experts think about what they told you
about the economy think of what they've
told you about what's happening on the
southern border think what they've told
you about the vaccines think of what
they told you about the ccp virus in the
origins of this virus in wuhan
think about that think about every day
that it's all a nut case conservancy
theory and then you get more information
and all sudden it's not okay think about
this war think of what you were told
about afghanistan
think about think about what you were
told about the american citizen left
there just think about what you're told
and then later what you find out to be
right and it's not marginal enough
people can make mistakes it's the exact
opposite of what you were told don't you
remember or or i don't know if you can
actually remember the feeling of being
totally disassociated from politics and
and and what was going on and you just
watched football you went to the bar you
had pizza wasn't that that warm fuzzy
feeling where you'd wake up and just do
your routine
it's all gone isn't it it's a fourth
turning that's that's that's a pre
fourth time this is where the fourth
turning is we're in the maelstrom right
now we're in the maelstrom and the whole
watching football and kind of living in
in a haze of glory we were on the back
of slaves we were living off the back of
slaves the whole time we just didn't
know but it's the exactly it's the
ignorance you were you you're basking in
the bliss of ignorance and more and more
that's where they want you to be right
remember that most of what's happened
this is what's so powerful i want to go
back to the apes and why they hate the
apes so much what are the apes doing
this so bad
they're buying american companies and
holding the stocks
okay they're they're racist they're
nativists they're they're they're
they're market manipulators they're
everything the press beats on these
people all day you know why
because they're crowdsourcing knowledge
they want you to be an idiot they want
you to look at the pro wrestling and
think about a second all the major
events that really happened 911 the war
in iraq the financial implosion in 2008
the market these things
how at the time
that you go back and look what was
covered on cable tv it's all pro
wrestling in the foreground they want
you distracted not just with
entertainment but even the stuff they
say is serious politics is all pro
wrestling it doesn't matter where the
power things that's what this bloomberg
article we're gonna get to read it 838
million dollars an hour okay four
trillion dollars and haven't even
started and it's not going to get
reversed unless you unless you throw
down hard and reverse it you ever hear
about the debt ceiling they don't want
you to know about that they don't want
you to know that you have the power to
say no they want you to be an idiot did
you know the u.s is liquidating its
assets to try and cover costs because of
the debt ceiling okay we talked about
okay the debt ceiling we're the only
show i think to pick up even the
business president when when yellen
remember she's the only person i believe
to be chairman of the federal reserve
and secretary of the treasury okay so in
those circles she's very highly regarded
she gives testimony right before fourth
of july and says oh by the way you know
on july 31st the debts we hit the debt
ceiling and we will default on
government securities on august 15th i
go oh my god this guy we will default
last time i looked it means you're
bankrupt okay
and you see there that
and they here's the games they play and
this is what the unit party plays
she's got to shuffle around they go
through the the 31st and nothing no
increase the debt ceiling and what are
they doing they're playing three-card
money they're taking money from social
security they're not putting money into
government pensions they're doing
they're going out and getting tomato
cans in the back of the federal reserve
where's the cash no they're doing
everything they can do
every and this remember these are the p
these are your betters
these are the people that think you're
an idiot and treat you like an idiot
these are supposed to be the geniuses
this is all the mckinsey consultant booz
allen they went to the best law schools
the best business schools they're your
betters okay you're better as goddess
afghanistan and the deplorables are over
in arlington national cemetery okay your
bettors are sitting there on the on the
think tanks and on msnbc and they're
they're giving these proclamations and
the deplorables kids are on those planes
going in there in to 6500 to try to save
american citizens and they're the ones
on the receiving ends of the afghani
kids are being tossed them over barbed
wire okay
that's the same thing here your betters
now they're running around getting cash
out of the tomato cans and back of the
federal reserve to kick the can down the
road till they get back from vacation
they can't handle it in august august is
recess we're coming back after september
20th then they're gonna have this false
deadline of october first and here's the
beauty of it it's gonna be your fault
you're the deplorables oh my gosh you're
gonna blow up the capital markets the
debt markets we're gonna default on
security you're the problem
you're the problem they're not the
problem how do you get us in here 28
trillion dollars and now they're talking
about another 6 trillion and there's
going to be a 6 trillion on top of that
on top of that here's why as long as
they can keep printing and the only way
they can keep printing the full faith
and credit of the united states
government is you it's not them it's you
on your back okay because you're going
to owe it back on your back they're
going to keep printing and printing and
printing and zero interest rates the
asset classes keep going and who owns
the assets they do they own the real
estate they own the stocks you own
nothing
fifty percent of the american people
can't put four hundred dollars in cash
together
cash together for an emergency
you're two paychecks away from oblivion
you don't own anything and you're not
going to own anything this is the system
that has i'm a capitalist this system
has to be dismantled and it can be
dismantled by the american people if we
act today do you think that the american
people are looking at a future much like
how the how the the chinese citizens
live where you're you're effectively
doing slave labor for for trash prices
tim poole you can't say what we want to
say on here
because you could be taken off by social
media oligarchs let's be brutally frank
that's right if you and i had the real
conversation that you want to have here
and you're smart enough and your staff
smart enough that's not the conversation
totally okay why
because the the social media oligarchs
they have the ability to take off a
sitting president and shut him up that's
why it's more powerful said this he told
me years ago he said social media is
more powerful than the nuclear weapons
like what are you talking about he goes
nuclear weapons if if if beijing
launches one to you you're gonna launch
two back and it'll stop social media
they can shut down anybody including a
commander-in-chief and that's what they
did they're told they will shut you down
if you get out of line the social credit
scores what do you think the vaccine
passports are the vaccine mandates is
your first social credit score right you
can't go in a restaurant and eat and
wash in in new york city you can't get
on an airplane you can't go you can't go
where you want in this country there's
no freedom social credit score this is
state capitalism and authoritarianism
and it's come here today in this country
we were talking with ben stewart about
the fourth turning
and one of the ideas of the fourth
turning is that the mo
in every fourth turning the most
powerful weapons available at the time
will be used in the conflict yes and i
said that's not nuclear weapons it's
social media boom the ability so i i've
long talked about this she knows that
that's why jack ma is looking for a job
right now right he cut him right off at
that point why
why why do we go to war why why was why
was violence used they were trying to
gain control of something they wanted
something they would take it or they
hate it you know there's often
ideological things but a lot of war is
resources i mean i think it's funny how
many people died about human history to
make food taste better for instance you
know all the spices and the trades and
everything that that you know how many
empires were built on that right right
right
but what happens when you no longer need
to use coerc physical or kinetic force
to command someone to your will well why
expend the energy cost when you can
instead
perhaps pay people 50 cents to post
propaganda in their free time exactly
because it's cyber it's cyber and
information warfare just like economic
warfare kinetic warfare is the most
is the most inefficient right you only
do kinetic warfare and when you have
overwhelming odds but i think we're
sliding to kinetic war because i think
we're weak but you're right the biggest
power is information cyber
you can if you can convince the enemy
nation to lay down their arms and wave
to you and cheer as you enter and you
don't need to waste money on on kinetic
weapons and if you can convince the
populist to pay you a percentage of
their income then you don't have to make
them slaves because they're already
you're already making money you've pers
you've you've fractionalized the slavery
instead of having one free person who's
running a business and one slave make
them all that's 40 by the way this is
what wall street does today let's if you
take this scam of money managers
i don't think there's any money managers
over time that have outperformed s p 400
that's why all these uh
uh instruments came up you can just
basically buy the market as a tracker
stock because they haven't over
performed just buying the market and how
the american economy grows and how
stocks relate to that yet your pension
fund money and that's every nurse every
cop
every uh every union member or people
your your money is institutional money
is managed the wall street guys get 20
they get a fee of one or two percent on
assets under management and when you're
talking billions that's real money
that's how they get the house and the
hamptons and the big parties but they
get 20 of the ops off your money and
here's what they did with that they ship
the jobs to china they ship the jobs to
time on your nickel the greek tragedy
part of this
is that working-class people of both
political persuasions
it's
you paid for it all your taxes
and your pension funds are what paid for
this whole thing the whole thing you
have
the ultimate power all power resides
with working-class people in this
country and that's the thing they don't
want you to know because you have the
power it's your money
it's your money and you could throw
these bums out and that's why they put
the pro wrestling to divide you in the
foreground because they don't want to
talk about the for the bloomberg article
today they don't really want to walk
through what's in these six trillion
dollars of spending it's a 2700 page
bill has anybody explained that bill to
you wow has anybody sat there and said
let me take an hour and walk you through
where 1.25 trillion dollars that you and
your kids are going to pay back let's
let's at least have enough respect for
you that will explain to you no you will
not see that anywhere because they're
never going to do it you know why they
understand an informed electorate is
informed consent right they don't want
that they want you to be
they want you to be distracted by the
bread and circuses on one level of pop
entertainment but also when you get into
politics or it's cable news it's all pro
wrestling it's not the real it's not the
thing itself if it's the thing itself we
wouldn't have these kind of issues that
pop up out of nowhere let's go to super
chats and i'm going to try and find
i'm i'm gonna try and focus on good
questions for steve so you can you know
usually we'll just read a lot and no
disrespect to a lot of people super
chatting i'm gonna try and go for the
good questions and and a couple of
snarky ones are good but that's okay no
i just mean there's a lot where people
like you know have comments about ideas
for the show or cast but i want to try
and get to you know good topics that we
can you know best utilize your time we
have one from nathan o'connell he says
tim love your show just want to remind
you the naval ship that burnt down in
san diego was set fire by a sealed
dropout if you think america is ready
for global conflict let me just say we
are repairing our carriers with chinese
stainless steel this is a brilliant
thing a four billion dollar a four
billion the bonhomme richard
a four billion dollar capital ship
burned down and we don't even know if
it's that guy but they say it's that guy
one person burned it down at a dock and
nobody's held responsible nobody wants
to talk about it this shows you the rot
in the system there should be admirals
fired about this we should get to the
bottom of it i still do not believe
having been a naval officer at the 32nd
street naval station new york in in san
diego that a single guy can start a fire
on a ship that can burn down a 4 billion
capital ship what was it what's the name
of the ship the bonhomme richard
that sounds like the what they do with
the reichstag
one guy burned down the reichstag is the
official story about it apparently it's
impossible exactly that's a great
question though by the way that should
be investigated and i think there are
independent people out there
investigating it all right we have
ariane amicus says i work for a
restaurant chain in minnesota we are
having trouble getting food and even the
deliveries to the point where our orders
do uh that to the point where when our
orders do come through half the order is
missing
i don't know what
you know where do you think we're headed
in that regard i think listen i think i
think that the inflation is not
transitory i think we have big supply
issues right i think the system's out of
whack and i think you're going to see
more of this i think you're pr look i
think
prices have not exploded like they're
going to explode and remember let me say
one thing about inflation steve cortez
said this today on the on the show
the reason i really got involved in
policies i made a film on reagan but
hadn't made one and that was in 2004 had
made one until the financial crisis and
i said hey when ever you've had a
financial crisis you always have a
populist reaction to that and this will
be interesting this really could be the
rise of populism right but
what you've seen in the past
when hyper inflation starts and then
inflation starts to get some momentum
on uh
homogeneous societies homogeneous
societies
right that it's still been massive
disruption we are a was a disputative
society right now we're kind of like a
dumpster finding a lot of regards at
each other's throats if you start to
have inflation start to hit and then
even mini hyperinflation
katie bar the door yes we have no
earthly idea this is why we're playing
with fire these people on wall street
these people in the government are
playing with fire and this is why you
need working-class people to step up say
i'm a run for office throw these bums
out we can't do this because the
inflation doesn't affect them you think
it affects the wealthy it stuff's a
little high a little more so it's
eight bucks to put into their uh into
their uh you know the land rover suv it
kills the working mom that's working two
jobs that takes away all the juice she's
gotten two paychecks when she's when
she's working 14 15 hours a day and half
a day on saturday okay that it doesn't
bother the wealthy right it doesn't
bother and doesn't buy the global
corporations the entrepreneur gets
squeezed remember all the stuff that
comes into the the sources like the
restaurant for the little entrepreneur
is all made by the big corporations
they're they're they're benefiting from
the inflation okay
they're benefiting the inflation hey
guess what's not inflating at the same
rate your wages
okay remember the whole game here is to
keep your wages down the misallocation
to returns on capital versus labor is
the central issue since 1972
there's been no real wage increase
except for 2019 under trump
okay there's been no wage increase for
the american worker look at the wealth
that's been created in this nation since
then have you participated in it have
your children present i don't care your
race your ethnicity
your level of education
your religion your gender your sexual
preference
since 1972
really the beginning of globalization
also coming off the gold standard but
the arab embargo all that
the american worker has taken it has
been shafted okay has been shafted and
all the wealth that's been created in
this country all the wealth has been
created by this country in other
countries all the middle classes of
other nations i have no problem with
people coming into the middle class all
the wealth has been created through the
world on the back of the american worker
on the back more importantly of your
pension fund which you got a taste of oh
yeah stock market you got a taste you
got a taste okay that's the the thing's
going to define us is how do you start
to take the returns to capital and start
to put it to labor so that working class
people for your time for your agency for
your human agency that time in life
you're here how do you get paid more for
it and not just that how do you able to
keep more the wealth that's created
around your efforts
all right coldwater says
please look up what happened today at
the black lives matter antiva conference
in portland they were confronted by a
woman whose husband was targeted by them
all the cameras were rolling and it was
epic you know recently we saw
a clash with right-wing groups and
left-wing groups in portland there was a
shootout
seems to be worse than we've seen in the
past although you know thankfully i
don't think anybody nobody died we have
seen people killed i'm curious that's
pro wrestling that's what they want you
to divertify that's totally pro
wrestling it's not meaningful
it's a handful of people and he said
yeah you got bad actors in the each side
you got you got some people there are
there for the right reason they have
causes it's pro wrestling they got you
down there and you're watching that
you're watching the videos you
deconstructed all the talk radio shows
at night and talk radio will be on it
forever it doesn't matter
it's pro wrestling you know what's
matters they're about to delay on six
trillion dollars that they're skimming
off the top of the value all the
lobbyists why are 19 republicans voting
for this they're supposed to be the
fiscally prudent ones why are they
voting for this unpaid for you wouldn't
do this for trump
trump had to pay for everything the
congressional budget not war room not
ben and not tim paul 286 billion dollar
air pocket new york times 400 billion
dollars and i will tell you if they had
the decency to walk you through it you
would see that none of it's paid for
it's all lies okay why the lobbyists are
making out everybody's got their hand
out and they spread it onto little
districts right so you can get you're
going to get a crumb you're going to
crumb and they're keeping the vigorous
that's the system there's not a
conspiracy that's the way the system
works they want you to be an idiot they
want you to focus on blm attacking proud
boys a group of guys you know should be
out drinking beer somewhere beating up
some other people and they're beating
them up and also we're gonna spend all
this time in it that's the pro wrestling
it's in the foreground it's to divert
your attention from what the reality is
all right durna 1804 says if we spent 62
billion in baltimore to build the city
up it would be the same result as
afghanistan crooked politicians would
steal it and give it to their friends it
works the same everywhere
i okay
a point taken but that's hang on but
that's why you have action in baltimore
and in saint louis and in detroit to sit
there and take action get citizens
involved and even if they skim 20 off
the top at least it's skimmed in america
okay and roll back into the community
you're right but you can have better if
you had spent the two trillion dollars
here in your great point the opportunity
cost if you invested it in advance
fourth industrial manufacturing into
these cities yes we would have a
paradise and that paradise is before us
because we're still the most productive
nation on earth we're still the most
wealthiest nation on earth but we're
we're dissipating that we're dissipating
our blood and our treasure because
remember
look at afghanistan at the end of the
day you are nothing but trash your trash
that they can throw out okay you can be
discarded you mean nothing to them all
you are is a thing to pay taxes send
your kids overseas keep your mouth shut
and follow your mandates that's what you
are they don't care about your opinion
in fact your opinion bothers them and
what they'd rather do is have you look
at the foreground of fighting each other
so that they can sit there make the
deals that they skim off the top and
have the greatest concentration of
wealth and power in world history
yeah you got me worked up pool i'm good
i don't get this worked up in the war
room i get it i
it must be harper's fairy right it's
like john the ghost of john brown still
hear us and get me all worked up
b says i think it's your producer
all right b says hartford connecticut
public schools requiring all math
teachers read and fill out an 83-page
critical race praxis workbook it says
you can find the pdf at
equitablemath.org
so yeah let's uh yeah what do you think
about what's going on with this
in in the context of everything right we
have you mentioned black lives matter
antifa proud voice fights it's
attraction what do you think about the
critical race applied principles
listen we turned the entire public
education system over for to stem
science technology engineering math yet
uh uh enough african-americans his banks
just don't get into engineering schools
and computers and there's nobody working
in silicon valley that's where they got
to have these h1
visas and look i love the chinese my
show is is is all about the lao beijing
the chinese i love china i'm the
chairman of the of the republican hindu
association i love india and the indians
but
i want these jobs for americans
right now african americans and
hispanics are plenty smart enough what
we have to do is be more rigorous in
math not less rigorous more rigorous in
math
they'll become the program remember in
fourth industrial revolution
so much of it is going to be in software
so much is going to be in programming
you're not going to everybody's not
going to be a programmer but the fourth
industrial manufacturing revolution is
going to require
our basic workers to step up to higher
levels right of knowledge
our african-american hispanic
communities have that
but not if you dumb it down and do soft
racism that this is what this is the
greatest crime going
they should participate by the way
silicon valley in these jobs should be
packed with african-americans and
hispanics not at 0.0 right and the
engineering schools should not take the
foreign students it's not that i don't
love the foreign students but i went to
a land-grant university the graduate
school now thinks 75
the reason is is that here's the scam
in-state students pay in-state tuition
foreign students pay full-ride and the
government's finance it the spread is
what pays for these faculties that's the
scam your kids because you're in state
whether you're black white hispanic
whatever
whatever your ethnicity or religion is
you're paying a going rate of this the
foreign students are paying to go and
rate that that arbitrage paid for by
foreign governments that's why there's
so many foreign students in these
engineering schools and look don't get
me wrong i love the foreign students but
american citizenship has to come
all the burdens on you your kids serve
in the military you pay the taxes your
pension fund funds everything the whole
burden is on your shoulders you got 400
in your bank account 90 of your net
worth is tied up in your home equity
right you're two paychecks away from
oblivion and you know it you get bounced
out you're two paychecks away from
having to go get welfare right after
being here for five six seven eight
generations you've got nothing to show
for it yet all this wealth has been
passed down you've got nothing right
they want the whole burden on you
and now they want to import the world to
compete against your kids for those jobs
no american citizenship has a premium
and let me be very simple you get the
first right to the best jobs and you get
a right to get of a foreign country
where your government's been there and
you're in some ngo and some progressive
from brown university who's working for
female rights i got no problem with that
if that's what you dedicate your life to
do in afghanistan but you know what when
it hits the fan you're coming out first
okay and now you're treated like trash
and that's the problem in this country
and when people get a belly full of it
that my citizenship not only doesn't
mean anything i get all the burdens when
none of the upside and the whole world
is supported on my shoulders because it
is supported on your shoulders
that's when you're going to have a
revolution in this country and that's
when people want to throw these bums out
tim miner says steve
the four that you mentioned trump pence
cuomo and newsome desantis and harris
replaced pence and cuomo when newsome
leaves which dem will replace him
i i don't know
it's irrelevant and look at larry elle
is a fine guy it's to me it's irrelevant
who replaces him it's because you're
there for six months you gotta get it
but it's very important that newsome be
resolved and by the way i totally
disagree with harris and with uh and
with um and with desantis
my point i'm making that you had four
rock stars and in this moment they're
all gone or four people who are at the
top of the game and they're gone in a
flash anything can happen now the one
thing about the fourth train that's the
most important thing
is go back and look at the revolution
the civil war the great depression world
war ii and now we're in people who are
all total schmendricks you've never
heard of before all the big actors get
washed away
all the big actors for the civil war get
washed away and you've got a railroad
lawyer lincoln you've got a you've got a
guy fighting the comanches down there in
san antonio texas robert e lee
you've got uh you've got a drunk in and
and and in uh in grant you've got
sherman who they think is crazy running
a military academy in louisiana these
are all marginal players they're
marginal they're super marginal and they
all become the major actors just like in
world war ii just on the revolution
you're seeing it now nobody who's a
temple is now you're one of the major
people and and you've got a you've got a
a community
right that you drive information to on a
daily basis this is what a fourth
tourney is about you're gonna see all
kind of people pop up
right maybe descended but you're gonna
see all people the type of people pop up
that you didn't think of before they
were all marginal donald j trump he's a
perfect fourth turning character here's
a guy's a real estate mogul a reality tv
star a guy that knows brands and all
sudden not only is he president i think
he's the most one of the most
significant presidents i put him up with
with jackson lincoln roosevelt and and
uh and in fdr and reagan and people say
you're crazy no he changed the direction
of this country okay that's why he's
going to come back but he's changed the
direction of this country and even if
you hate the sound of his name
think of what the country was before the
ccp virus hit and think of where it is
today look at look at around the world
and look at all the bad actors she the
mullahs in iran right the erdogan uh
putin look at those actors on the
eurasian landmass compared to what
they're doing they're licking their
chops at the end of america
jay rich says fast food restaurants are
advertising to 25 an hour in my area
central oregon inflation is hitting
harder and harder what is the end result
of this how long will it take and what
is the best way to invest a couple
hundred k right now
i'm never getting financial advice no
what i would do about financial advice
here's what i would do i tell anybody go
to these chat rooms and just hang out
and listen to the apes into the lectures
they have learn the fundamentals and
rudimentary elements of the system learn
the system you can't deconstruct it till
you learn it learn about finance learn
even if you're not mathematically
inclined you've never invested in your
life there's information out there and i
think you see in these communities
there's a certain joy to learning
particularly
they go out of their way not to teach
you anything about personal finance they
go through a way not to teach anything
about macro finance you don't know how
the government works you don't have the
monies funded you don't know this they
want it in like some some sort of high
priesthood so they can sit there and
pontificate from wall street the wall
street journal and the editorial pages
it's all a scam it's all a con it's all
your money comes off it gets back to
coming off the sweat of your brow okay
that's what drives the value in this
country
okay and yes and here's what i like
about the twenty five dollars an hour
this one that's why i'm a restrictionist
on immigration
you know why until we get everybody in a
good job
everybody in a good job we got enough
okay everybody says oh we gotta add you
know why because they want to drive
wages that if it takes 25 bucks to flip
a burger and a burger cost some more hey
so be it if that cost is in the labor
right that's what i'm a restrictionist
so
but this inflation i think and here's
what's going to happen the more money
they print the more money they print the
higher the inflation is going to go and
right now
it's out of control in washington dc
right now you see oh they got there
she's cutting these deals she's doing
all this they're calling back this is
going to
make you a r your russian surf right now
this is going to make you an
impoverished russian surf this is like a
20
increase to the monetary supply if they
print 6 trillion which would mean 20
percent more inflation on top of what
we've already seen then i would imagine
another printing beyond six trillion
there's not a direct correlation but
directionally you're absolutely correct
that's the weight that's that's the way
you guys start thinking about it
remember there's three ways to pay for
things i just want to make sure people
understand three ways to pay for things
in their government you sell the bonds
to like japanese insurance companies or
the chinese communist party owns a
trillion dollars and they're not doing
it because they like us they need that
spread they need that interest payment
to pay for their things okay because our
instruments do have returns on them do
they have yields
and the gulf emirates but that you can
only pay they get an appetite
their appetite can be sated okay fairly
quickly second way is you raise taxes or
tax you have grow you don't have to
raise them if you have a growth curve
we're in flat growth right now okay flat
growth at least trump gave you growth
right
the third way
is you just print money just literally
make it up the government basically
the treasury department we the federal
reserve buys the notes that are issued
by the treasury well how can you do that
the only way you can do that is cause on
your back because everybody's gotta take
the dollar it's we're the prime reserve
currency the dollars drive the system
once we become once they once that's
crypto or the remember the big deal in
china is this deal with saudi arabia and
the persians they already got a 40-year
deal
uh with 25-year deal with iran they're
trying to cut a long-term deal with the
the arab with saudi arabia's publicly
traded company which is upside down in a
disaster to do a long-term output deal
but take it in r b taking it take break
putin these guys are thinking nonstop
how do we get off the dollar because
this is the way the americans can still
control us
once that happens ladies and gentlemen
we're we're argentina what i mean by
that argentina 100 years ago was one of
the wealthiest nations on earth
it was a paradise
it's been a disaster for a hundred years
and you had perone and fascists and
everything it's been a disaster why
because they printed too much money they
they got they got debt out of control
and that's where we're heading and by
the way
look at afghanistan and
look at it watch it every night
because the financial debacle all your
bettors all the geniuses told you for 20
years and 2 trillion dollars and 6 000
dead and 25 000 wounded and people with
ptsd they all told you it's fine we're
building a democracy and they're voting
it's all great right and the taliban's
gone all of it it was all lies
when the financial firestorm comes it's
going to be 10x what afghanistan is in
your personal life and they're going to
tell you the same crap right you're
betters your betters your betters if
they're so smart why are we in this mess
this one's interesting
mr m says tim i have a friend that works
in shipping cargo containers in 2019 he
said a container would cost two thousand
dollars to ship this year it's twenty
one thousand dollars hello that's gonna
hit all of the goods you gotta get
imported hello yeah hello
supply chain cost
hello yeah we we we looked at a lot uh
over at temcast.com we deep dive into
the food supply stuff it's scary stuff
by the way this is the best thing about
shows like this the crowd sourcing and
natural knowledge like that putting it
up this is from your own personal life
your own personal you don't need the big
textbooks at harvard and all these
professors just look around you in your
own personal life you're seeing it today
in every aspect of your professional
personal life
all right nicholas
caracappa says question for steve is it
possible to establish a microchip
manufacturing base here in the u.s this
is a project steve can start this would
bring high-tech manufacturing jobs to
the us reduce the fallout if china takes
taiwan and potentially avoid a conflict
with china that's a brilliant question
by the way so in the infrastructure bill
there is 20 billion dollars for trying
to do it navarre and i fought for this
in the summer of 17. we were actually
thwarted
around president trump by the free
market guys remember i'm not i'm not i'm
not a free market guy because there are
no free markets it's all mercantilism
right we need to bring and i think in
conjunction with the taiwanese look
have we run out of time maybe but yes
you're absolutely correct we've got to
bring back advanced chip design and
advanced chip design manufacturing to
the united states i got a perfect
example arizona navajo nation right up
at tuba city let's make it the microchip
capital of the world that's a brilliant
this is why
i believe in economic nationalism this
is what we have to start thinking of
this is what we have to start focusing
on these type of things and and you
would be surprised that brilliant
observation and it's brilliant
is thwarted by so many people oh we
can't do that free markets you don't
want to you don't want to turn to free
markets with no it's not a free market
and right now we're exposed
strategically
strategically in the most vulnerable
thing we can advance chip design because
that gentleman's observations have not
been have not been put into effect
for 20 years we might be able to build
uh software and technology that lets you
print your
chips in your house so everyone has
access to the information and can print
whatever chips they need on on demand it
wouldn't be as much of a profit thing
for the country but it would probably
better for humanity to decentralize the
information if you can invent a printer
that can do all of that in one go
you know like a print paper with graph i
mean just talk about graphing let's go
dude i knew he was working
i knew he was going to get him in there
somewhere i know he's going to get it in
summer are you are you like are they a
sponsor of yours yeah
you're a lobbyist
no i'm serious
there's something there's something
hinky here's a lot of money we got a
summer arbor gas says what does a social
score look like
how do you think a social credit score
would uh would manifest well i think i
think a social credit score right now in
china you actually have it right where
you can't get on a plane you can't do
things your kids can't go to school so
they keep a score under you are you
asking questions do your neighbors think
you're too nosy in the party's affairs
here's social credit score let's start
off with it it's uh it's it's going to
be the vaccine passport that's going to
score are you vaccinated or not boom
that's that's going to be apartheid
you're going to be othered you're going
to be in the leopard colony right
immediately so social credit score is
going to look at right there i don't
know what the ratings are going to be
but you're already seeing lines of
demarcation remember look at how many
people are associated with president
trump
that have been de uh d-platform on
social media have been de-banked right
have been
across the board you know this if you
start going out there and start being a
fire breather they're gonna make it
tougher and pay pal in these other
situations to actually run your business
that's all social credit score right
okay so
it's not coming to the united states
it's here yeah we have social credit
store here in the united states of
america right now and there's no court
you can go back and argue about it it
just is look at dave rubin on twitter
you're just all of a sudden you're
banned you're gone you don't know for a
while it wasn't just temporarily just
temporarily but you don't know the
ground rules you get back up in a couple
of weeks but you can be banned look we i
was banned permanently on the war room
i've never had a twitter account there's
a hundred fake ones out there but on
once we had the war room they said oh
because you said things about fauci and
chris ray metaphorical things i was
talking about thomas more
a couple days before but the real reason
we were banned is we were putting out
the hard drive from hell every day we
put out both the porn and the and the
and and the in the compromise by the
chinese commerce party what they were
paid they wanted that out and they took
the whole thing down permanently
permanently banned
all right and we'll get into a lot of
that stuff obviously at timcast.com in
the members segment which i'm excited
for but uh we did we still have some
really good questions i think i'm gonna
pay for that tonight yeah great i'm
gonna i wanna i wanna see this good
investment all right no because i wanna
know the graph i wanna the punch line of
graphene we're gonna get to it we're
gonna do it this is a good one though
freeze falcon says mr bannon what is
your opinion on mr kushner's peace deals
in the middle east do you hear from
kushner at all rumor has it he wants
back in
well what do you think about the peace
deals here's why
look for the abraham accords which came
up from the last thing were they perfect
no but man directionally were they
fantastic would you rather have that and
have countries talking to israel have
countries having flights trying to work
together in the region not at each
other's throats or what's happening in
the what we're leaving behind in
afghanistan is a terrorist super state
the haqqani network's there isis is
there al qaeda's there the taliban is
there yes i would rather have what
president trump listen let's be blunt if
that was obama they would give him
another nobel prize okay the the
these guys hammered and jared hammered
and the team that worked on it avi and
these guys hammered it out and as
imperfect as it is it's a fantastic
start and i think the first time in the
history of the region people actually
tried and these are not all great actors
actually started to work together would
people rather have the middle east like
it was back in the fall of 2019 when
they're getting ready to announce the
abrahamic courts and working on it or
would you rather have it today when
you're going to start to see
american citizens hunted down by the
taliban and our allies there
and who knows what happens to the women
to the children all that tell me which
one you'd rather have i'll pick the
abrahamic courts all right christopher
coulter says steve comments remind me of
three great books blink by malcolm
gladwell the wisdom of crowds by james
sir uh how you pronounce it surowaichi
suraweki
surowaiki and future babel by dan
gardner they all explain the limits of
expertism and why so-called experts
should always be questioned read them
all yes
also i think as layman had a book back
in the 90s really question started
questioning the
the experts forget the name of chris
christopher lash who died christopher
lash a brilliant guy christopher lash
wrote the first book that really kicked
it off about getting to a managerial
economy where the experts told you what
to do so those those three right there
are fantastic
all right
rainer chen says while america is
struggling to get its citizens out of
afghanistan china just took control of
multiple iron mines in africa and peru
neither interventionism nor isolationism
can save america learn mandarin guys
you going to learn mandarin no i'm not
going to learn mandarin by the way
because because the ch that allowed by
no man remember it's their freedom that
we're fighting for this transnational
criminal organization the chinese people
la baijing
throughout their history they don't want
to be in africa and they don't want to
be doing this they don't want to be
spending trillions of dollars which
they're getting ripped off too
they they live like slaves the suicide
rates in these factories are out of
control the social conditions the
environment it's awful remember they've
killed the chinese countries parties
killed 90 million people we know this
they've killed they've murdered 90
million since 1949 they're an
illegitimate government because they
lied about everything no land reform
nothing but more importantly they've
butchered murdered 400 million
forced abortions okay the hungry ghost
of the of the of the babies of china
right is what haunts this regime okay
they're a murderous dictatorship the
biggest victims are the chinese people
so no intervention doesn't work but we
shouldn't be intervening however we have
to confront
this criminal organization that's out to
control the world they are they ought to
control the world and by the way you see
their gangsterism spreading you see it
in pakistan you see it now in
afghanistan with the taliban and the
other terrorists you're going to see it
in india you'll see it in turkey you
already see it in the mullahs what
they're trying to do in the in the
persian gulf and maybe some of the less
democratic regimes there right they're
seeing in a partnership with russia
they're trying to control the eurasian
land mass and by the way go back to the
guns of august since 1914
the basic foreign policy of the united
states regardless of republican or
democrat
we will never allow one power or a a
combination of powers to control the
eurasian landmass that's essentially the
world idol if you really will look at
the planet as it is the western
hemisphere is a small island off of this
massive land mass that's eurasia land
mass mckinder kind of 101 who controls
who controls the eurasian landmass can
control the world the chinese communist
party is set to do it and that's why
with us on the run in afghanistan and i
the biggest believer in we had to end
that war and get out but you got to do
it a certain way they're looking right
now to drive us out of the pacific into
basically destroy our economy by an
attack on taiwan i'm gonna do one more
and it's a really important one chip
bradley says tim i ran and won a seat on
my city council in large part because of
you and your crew thank you for the
encouragement amen yes that's the most
important by the way
that's the way we're going to turn this
around if i can
go to your go to your committee meetings
whether if you're republican take over
the rnc if you democrat go take over the
democratic party okay with populism go
to city council go to your school board
action action action all politics is
local the whole apparatus depends on on
these localities that's where you can
get real power so right there that is
that is the coolest thing i've heard
about that that is what's going to lead
us to the sunlit uplands and we can get
there but it's going to be we have to
chop a lot of wood to get there my
friends there is a lot that we need to
talk about some inside jokes as well as
some very serious topics that are no no
topics on youtube which means go to
timcast.com become a member
usually we upload around 11 p.m but we
might end up running longer we'll see
we'll see how things play out but if you
go to timcast.com we'll have that member
segment up for you where we'll talk
about a lot of these very serious issues
you can also follow the show at timcast
irl on basically every platform you can
follow me at timcast if you want to
follow me personally and uh oh yeah like
like the video share it subscribe and
everything do you want to shout out
anything we're on getter the boardroom's
on getter i'm on getter but i don't know
my getter handle i think that's steve
bannon together i'm not really i'm not
really a social media but getter's
fantastic go to a war room also go to
worm.org you can see this all the time
and
love being on the show thank you so much
for having me here yeah right on first
hour flew by man that was really really
good info always good to see you stephen
uh good to see you hey thanks for coming
ian crossland following me on the
internet eddie and crossland again
crossland.net catch you later
the first hour flew by i thought both
hours slew by that was a very
revolutionary conversation with mr
bannon i have to say you guys are more
than welcome to follow me on twitter not
get her yet at sourpatch lids as i
attempt to gain more followers in sarah
patrick you may be the best producer in
the business i'm scared i'm serious
she's smooth she's good everything's
organized when you come here with tim
everything's organized it's all set
there's no we say every day
at the war room without tears i kind of
get a little antsy there that our team's
great but i have a tendency to get a
little ants they're listening downstairs
i get a lot they're laughing
you're the calming presence i gotta say
uh time flies but i'm really excited for
this next conversation
so check it out thanks for hanging out
again go to timcast.com be a member this
one's gonna be fun and we'll see you all
there
you